[Music]
[Applause]
it's friday baby august 19th
my my my how the time flies huh it sure
does you know what's crazy think about
this september
october november december there's like
four months and some change until the
new year bro
that's a broad moment right there
disgusting
right
yeah so anyway welcome everybody happy
fridays friday baby
welcome uh thank you to hellofresh for
joining us today i wanna introduce three
special guests right here so you guys
know who they are
uh we have our mod team
these excellent uh
men and women have been moderating
probably banning many of you are out
there
fear them
no they're good they're great people
they do amazing job
i'll just introduce them so you guys
know who they are and let's start with
avery
[Applause]
and i see cameron
uh has lented you one of his birds
that's excellent
oh look at that
yeah
the gentle giant yes
how tall are you avery um i'm six eight
so
big man
you almost like asked you know how you
actually step on a dog sometimes i mean
it happened
you almost stepped on afraid i was like
oh my god i'm afraid oh yeah i'm sorry
that happens
have you ever killed an animal under
under your foot yeah i love animals
please don't cancel me
so thank you avery well welcome back oh
you got the whole bambi forest
and then who else we got just switched
we got oh that's rey
welcome ray
another wonderful mod how are you ray
good
sorry
yes excellent
so how are you
i'm doing great this is very surreal
thank you guys okay yes of course thank
you for being here ray als you can step
on my animals they'll be fine
unlike avery
i'll still avoid it though yeah yeah
please yeah
avoiding stepping on animals folks they
love that
and kevin
where is kevin he's our third mod here
today
sitting next to zach
hey kevin how are you hello everybody
welcome what's interesting about kevin
you also do modding for tim hi decker
isn't that right yes i do for his office
hours live that's cool and there's i
mean and so which is your favorite
podcast yeah
earlier
the h3 podcast all right let's go
[Music]
thank you bro right answer he wore all
teddy fresh to tim's podcast
that's what that's what saw what's up
representing
foot soldier first and foremost my man
anyway so you guys feel free to chime in
if anything you know comes up
and uh
welcome to the show okay excellent
thank you for your service thank you for
your service absolutely
um
also quick shout out
to
i forgot to promote this yesterday but
hello hello fred
teddy fresh kind of close and
oh my god i never really didn't realize
just one word when you're done getting
your groceries come get your
outfit
it's teddy fresh our peanuts collab
just dropped all your favorite
characters from peanuts
are you here at teddyfish.com that's
right
anyone is anyone wearing the cam shirt
this shirt's great this one cameron's
wearing camera show camera and then
touch the snoo the snoopy see how soft
that is damn boy okay okay okay
nice avery avery loves it
work with me
uh these are just cool skirt and then oh
denim jacket show that off girl okay
okay it is um oversized so if you want
to feel kind of loosely gucci
no pictures please
yeah we got these cool all over print
shirts this one
the muscle tank on there no
oh damn
oh [ __ ] what's up damn girl okay
okay
about to make me act up
yeah this shirt here this is the one i'm
wearing it says
this one hits home with me
does it bother you knowing that nobody
likes you charlie brown
that's what ela says to me
it's a little upsetting not true does it
bother me
sometimes yeah most of the time stop
and born to sleep peanuts hot
some nice hoodies and stuff go check it
out teddybrush.com oh yeah this one's a
hit too this one socks
oh the socks are adorbs
not
not the best way to show socks but
they're really cute green socks are so
cute
you guys are talking about
anyway that's you guys know what to do
go to the thing and do the thing
thank you
um
so
what i'm wondering today
obviously you've seen the title of the
episode yeah andrew tate has
wow oh he's perished
nature is healing that's right you put
in a call to suicide
finally
you finally did it wait was he banned on
youtube
no but that would be too obvious you
called yeah he called zuckerberg
zuckerberg called the twitter guy i'm
sure keemstar is trying to figure out
how he can pin this on me right
yeah so he hasn't been banned on youtube
unfortunately
but he was banned on facebook and
instagram
and um
where else was he is it twitter facebook
and instagram yes yeah that's pretty
huge one that's like alex jones level
it's like you're off the planet
bye his youtube channel yeah
he's on twitch a lot that's the kind of
the other thing like he's on live now
with aidan ross right now being like
talking all kinds of [ __ ] and hayden
ross is just being like a pathetic sim
for him what a loser
okay wait this is a new ethan we're not
starting to use the dog like as a sign
so i can hold it
like that you know the bite dog yeah
oh bye
yeah so i've got details on that it's
going to be fun to talk about and tap
dance on his grave there he's a giant
piece of [ __ ]
little people being like are you really
in favor of d platforming [ __ ] he
should be in jail yes platforming i want
to de-platform his life he needs to
forfeit his freedom and be in jail he
platform him the way bill cosby was
deeply yeah exactly
you know something we nev i never got to
discuss are we talking about him or is
that are you just we can give you a
little preview oh we can do it now i
mean we're already in it okay i never
got to personally discuss the fact that
because he was making fun of me when i
wasn't on the show you you were watching
that clip or something
he was like making fun of how i look oh
is that the video he uploaded where he's
like this nerd is making fun like this
is your wife no wonder you're so bitter
kind of thing
um so i never got to say the picture i
was looking at i was like nine months
pregnant in that picture
yeah but you still look gorgeous it
doesn't even matter but it's like can
you guys watch that what a beta to make
fun of me in my nine-month
pregnancy yeah dude everything they do
is beta insecurity the man
anyway it's it's a long time ago but
i've always kind of like never got to
say that it's like
like
let me see you
sh don't show your muscles again because
he'll faint
yeah i'd like to see you get in the ring
with that loser
anyway so yeah and so let's get into it
then uh meta confirmed i'm not calling
facebook meta i'm just not gonna do it
[ __ ] me you know what i mean your
facebook nice try [ __ ]
i never i didn't forget about the
elections
metta
aka facebook confirmed that tate was
removed from facebook instagram for
violating its policies
and cited met as guidelines on dangerous
individuals and organizations straight
up mobster human trafficker
a specific reason was not given i find
it interesting that like
facebook instagram were like oh this
guy's a human trafficker
[Music]
let's get him off our platform but
youtube's like cool
i'm the meat chef
yeah and i mean they're at the cutting
edge of a lot of things technology is
one of them as dan
correctly points out
this is um
this is just so inspiring that this is
where technology is going yeah no that's
come a long way man i'm making meats now
smoking these meats here sims is the
pinnacle of uh graphics i just think
it's funny that this is the man who who
took down andrew tate okay we love that
for him this is your kryptonite dude
this is my hero
[Laughter]
actually speaking of this though uh what
is this from zuckerberg he keeps trying
to make vr happen i don't think from uh
it's facebook has a metaverse app kind
of it's similar to that you remember on
the show one time you live went on to
that uh nft metaverse thing this is like
a little bit of a fancier version of
that
um we actually tried to download it the
other day because we thought it'd be fun
to have you explore it but you need
a quest to it only works specifically
with the quest 2 vr headset which is not
the one that we have so i want to get
that up for next week yeah okay i want
to get in there let's get the question
quest for zuckerberg right he's in there
somewhere and i'm gonna find him
yeah so uh i guess he unveiled this you
can go tour paris got it and
it's super realistic it's obviously it's
just like the real thing the future of
like the value and of nfts and crypto
like this is the future right it's like
when we all live in the media
that's what that's what people say yeah
but no promising and also what's
interesting about meta is that they've
they're like hemorrhaging money like how
much have they spent on like this
project
alone i think
i think it was like 10 billion or
something which honestly for them is
probably not that bad i mean it's a lot
of [ __ ] money but
oh here it is in world it's called uh
thank you a b we've got the clip of
andrew
roasting
ethan klein's wife
who uploaded this oh god this is a tape
playboy
clip oh my god his own people posted
this [ __ ]
first of all bro just like what is he
wearing i'm saying like just stop my god
where you're at
oh my you don't even need to speak any
words breaking god
i mean he looks like a human trafficker
true
i guess he's dressing the part yeah yeah
yeah
by the way before i move on i'm all over
the place but facebook's parent meta
lost 2.8 billion on its virtual reality
division
during the quarter end in june
substantial sum is the latest sign that
ceo mark zuckerberg at meta continues to
spend heavily to pivot social media
giant to the so-called metaverse it's
not happening zak
i don't see how the [ __ ] he's going to
convert all the old people that are left
on facebook the only people left are
boomers how is they how are they getting
in meta
i don't know
but
godspeed at least you'd ban tate i want
tate in vr bro can you imagine
the first instance of like essay in in
vr
yeah but here's andrew tate uh
insulting eli klein which never goes
well for people google ethan's wife
oh my god how is that always the first
thing
look at this idiot who's happily married
with the family unbelievable i'm so used
to it by now it's just such a
self-reporting find it entertaining
every time
bro you guys are not disappointed dude
you're gonna die alone without a family
i mean that's sad bro i mean well so you
know some people choose that life but
you'll never find a meaningful companion
and i think that's sad
right damn
didn't
is it muted
not on our end no it's not i don't have
any audio oh he's just typing i'm just
typing again
oh it was their stream
i can't like at worst the thing is
they're trying so hard to try hard at
worst you're like
i'm sorry i don't i you don't see me and
you go jesus i did today i said it in a
slay i went jesus look at that outfit
thank you it's just such a ridiculous
overreaction like first of all
ela's beautiful obviously as everybody
knows
but
you can't even pretend like she's a
beast like come on dude
it's just not possible losers
yeah totally
but he used to be a bit i know the guys
can't see my screen right now but she
like he used to be quite skinny so what
he just got fat i mean his wife was
always basic ah my turbo base oh my god
i guess anyone without like
massive implants basic shoot that woman
would not even get on a webcam bro
basically
right
seriously
you can't even steal that guy's wife
because we cannot be seen with a woman
of that caliber in the compound
the compound
what is the compound that's the rape
you're a prisoner yes that's their
that's what they call their dungeon yeah
we can't have her here she's smiling she
might inspire the other women
that's true
you're trying so hard dude really you're
just gonna pull it up and call her ugly
that's the dub come on dude slammed
what if she holds the camera really you
know what i think we might fire
scott adam's life and hire ethan's wife
should we do that so this is this is
what oh this is the one they pull up
this
yeah with this photo anyway
absolutely nothing but also this is a
pregnancy photo
yeah but like nine months doesn't even
matter it's just like they're trying so
hard to make was like shut up dude
you're sitting there in like a [ __ ]
skin
a snakeskin jacket open i mean you are
like such a wannabe dude that's your
poser ass it's so funny it's like the
sweetest picture of you guys ever i know
also no here's happiness here's sadness
yeah exactly she's like okay let's see
which one's happy young couple about to
have their first baby yeah successful
independently successful
oh she wouldn't even leave my compound
bro
she wouldn't even do webcam service bro
stay down [ __ ] baby
[Laughter]
we don't get girls and this is his wife
let me tell you something ethan yeah you
think it's so defensive about that i
would rather
sleep in a bed by myself no
by himself oh god
aren't you scared of the dark how can
you be that brave to sleep by yourself i
thought you would need at least some
comfort at least mommy down the hall
that's just so brave
oh he sleep by himself
that's so
hard it's so scary when the lights are
off
[Applause]
i sleep by myself
[Music]
and will
keep the door open
andrew will you get in bed with me
it's too scary
will you turn on my paw patrol
nightlight andrew
that's really brave of him actually
respect wow right
he's going to sleep by himself
stunning and powerful
these guys are warriors i take
everything back
for the rest of my life
then marry a woman who looked like that
smart mutual so yeah have fun in your
bed by yourself for the rest of your
life that's what i was you know it's
like
good luck even finding a woman to be
with you in a capacity where they're not
making money i mean good luck i'd like
to even see that happen
it's hard to have a woman sleep with you
in a race car bed too so
let's go
yeah
it's a bugatti bed it's a bugatti it's a
bugatti baby bugatti bed i got a
matching watch with it brother oh my god
that's too funny
that's so funny and true
you guys are these you guys are so brave
even if i didn't get girls i'm doing
better than you that's negative girls
that's minus girls
alicia's hair is real christ real
hairline
by the way andrew's a [ __ ] beast just
look at this he's like a hideous person
and i mean i only say that
about him because you know he calls
people ugly he calls my wife ugly i'm
just saying you you cover your face and
body look how much you cover your face
bro it's because you know you look like
[ __ ] sloth from the goonies
he really does
let's be real you're sloth
the only difference is sloth was more it
was smarter more articulate
right so
that's how much does that look like him
if i look like that i'd wear big old
sunglasses too by the way the biggest
sunglasses i've ever seen
[Music]
sort your life out son but you know sort
your life out start your life back
that's the whole clip so i have a
message for andrew now that like he's
getting off of um
socials and he's gonna lose
i'm sure audience to scam for money
um slowly this business is going to you
know shrink and drought yeah yeah and
the money is going to slow down so yeah
i know he's going to be looking for a
job um
you can go ahead and send me a resume
i'll be sure to spit on it and throw it
in the trash
but we might have a position for him i
was gonna say i might have a new
position opening up
i do get thirsty a lot throughout the
day
i do need a boy yeah
so
maybe you can apply and you know are you
a fan of bubble water no oh so this
might not work out then yeah
a [ __ ] dozer maybe he'll make some
compromises yeah yeah if he's desperate
but my i mean they do have really good
work uh release programs in prison which
is where i think he's headed i mean
there's no way this guy didn't commit
like massive wire fraud internationally
there's no shot
there's no shot
um
let's look at the comments
andrew didn't even say anything was all
tristan i think andrew felt bad
as far as i'm concerned andrew simply
stayed quiet about his wife
this was i mean i don't know this was
not really quiet oh i feel bad for ela
here we go she seems genuinely nice
unlocks ethan
right now she's stuck with him i don't
know that wait what is this whole
sentence i'm not sure i thought unlock
ethan meant like this is the way to get
to ethan is to say stuff about eli
because you don't care when people
say stuff about you
but oh so like he's
i don't know
uh these people are not very literate
yeah
i honestly feel bad for you it's
supposed to be unlike ethan she's
generally a nice unlikely oh i'm like
i'm a big meanie um
i was mean to andrew
your special guy
him
you're bullying him
i'm a fan of these two but this is evil
why make fun of her looks
would the tate brothers like someone
mocking their mom or sister like this
okay player
you guys
[Laughter]
yo
why is that guy even listening to their
[ __ ] if he's that sensitive
yeah but actually in the new meta verse
there's a new
you can fight andrew tate in the
metaverse so that's super realistic
zupp knocks out cobra tate ladies and
gentlemen in the metaverse today
also
we got a nice comparison here between
sloth and hey
and i'm just saying
there is a lot of similarity
i do see it i see it
so we love that for him
yeah so he's banned which is i think
oh oh
hey gabe what's up buddy hello
it's friday [ __ ]
it's friday
hey how was your birthday
[Music]
how was your thursday gabe
it's great
how was your thursday
it's awesome baby okay all right
i like your theory on the weeks though
because i see you posting stuff like
thursday's just friday eve i like it
yeah yeah
hopefully i'll sell
we're trying to sell some content here
wait are you what do you mean you're
selling content
it's all like you know
trying to make my new show
oh oh okay tell me more i'm intrigued
pitch it to me you need a financier
which is better you know like we do food
let's say
let's say big mouth and whopper that
kind of stuff or coke and pepsi
something like that that's just an
example we're trying to make a
comparison what people like okay and
you've seen and you feel you're in a
unique position to give us that that
comparison analysis
we're gonna we're gonna try
[ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
we're gonna try i watch that
i'd watch the [ __ ] out of that
where's that going on tick tock
instagram oh instagram tits in my dick
[ __ ]
[Music]
hey check this out gabe we ran a poll
before the show
to see uh
what was everyone's favorite catch
phrase of yours
you want to see the results
this in my ass [ __ ] so here i'll give
you the results okay
there was there was four options so i'll
read them to you from worst or least
like to most favorite okay oh sure so
the the least liked is [ __ ] on my tits
[ __ ]
i think that doesn't make sense
all right get on my tits
you know my kids
that's a sex act i mean you could
perform that
yeah
um so i don't know i like that one maybe
it's maybe i'm taking it personally
because you know i think that was my
baby but it's eight percent
so the next one gabe the most liked one
is horse [ __ ] energy [ __ ]
[Applause]
and then the next one is hasta la vista
[ __ ]
and this one was very very close
to the winner everyone's favorite
catchphrase of yours is pissing my ass
[ __ ]
[Applause]
that's a that's a fan favorite
[Applause]
i love that one too
yeah so i don't know if you want to do
something with that
but um what do you what you got plans
for the weekend
well right now um
we're gonna we're having um like papa
john's we're having that special thing
and then on the weekend we're yeah
that's nickname we're going to vegas
baby
[Applause]
what flavor did you get
i got um
pepperoni and sausage
do you find do you find that there's too
many vegetables in it
well
i don't think of it that way
too many vegetables
it's not really fulfilling oh oh you got
a little soda from the off camera that's
nice service
that's a nice service you got there
brother what kind of smoke are you
kicking back
[Applause]
that was hype as [ __ ] oh yeah take your
time
those things make you thirsty there's a
lot of salt in it oh wow
closing the bottle too wow
man you are a king dude gabe is the king
of the homeworld
yes so how do you like the ball
what happened how do you like
[Laughter]
how do you like the bowl
that's good
with that bread that's good for people
that um that are in a keto diet but like
you know pizza this is kind of the
alternative right there yeah
yeah so you think you're going to finish
that whole thing
i don't know
later
yeah okay okay
all right buddy well it sounds like you
got your whole weekend ahead of you so i
want you guys to enjoy that
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] pissing my [ __ ]
what about pissing my [ __ ] ass
ow maybe try like a real painful one
like it's friday baby ow
yeah that's an interesting twist
all right you guys have fun okay all
right we have a good one all right y'all
take care love you have a good weekend
have fun
have fun buddy
careful with that bowl okay
all right you're playing with dark
powers there with that
bull right you take care papa didn't
condone that bull by the way
yeah all right take care buddy have fun
all right you have a good one all right
you too buddy
all right take care now
wow
ew how do you convey to him that you're
thirsty or does he just hand it to you
it just ended
shout out nick nick
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
take care buddy all right
oh he hung up
wow that's the first time he's hung up
i just wanted to see what would happen
if i just let it hang i'll tell you what
i love that man with all my heart soul
gabe is such a he's such a pure soul
he's such a great guy
shout out to white claw gabe he's on
cameo if you want to support him
yeah talented musician
so we were talking about andrew tate um
yeah so do you find it interesting that
facebook was the one
yeah to bring justice for once because
it seems like
youtube is usually faster to act on
these issues yeah
or i don't know i don't know about that
or i guess
we did it first was it uh because it's
also twitter right
so
he has technically been banned on
twitter for years oh um but he had
secret alts um that was open secret like
yeah people obviously knew it was him um
but
uh
they're constantly stamping out those
alts and so that's actually
the instagram and facebook thing is the
bigger news because that's the big one
yeah
yeah but so there you go i mean round of
applause i mean in a happy [ __ ] you to
andrew tate and his dumb ass brother
please clap
suck my dick [ __ ]
we need a um jordan peterson [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
here's a screenshot of his instagram
what did he have a really big instagram
page 4.7 million i'll see you later [ __ ]
boy [ __ ] you if you don't like it
it's just empty
yeah like this see how he's sitting
alone by himself right that's you now
four time kickboxing world champ come on
well of what of what classes the [ __ ]
uh karate kid [ __ ]
against of the all valley tournament
yeah under 18 15 year olds
cobra tate never dies cobra kai never
dies
i love that love to see it
love the tap dance on your grave my
friend
yeah 4.7 million and then hus uh
oh is hassan having a meltdown about
this
yeah he's upset oh [ __ ] hassan is pissed
my my co-host he says if they can bend
and you tate they can ban all of us rise
up tater tots
you know that's true
it's kind of like what they're saying
about trump i mean if they can go for
trump having nuclear secrets then they
can come for any of us yep
i love the tater tots
come from my nuclear secrets
encompass your nuclear secrets
or your sex dungeon you know god damn oh
he's trending this isn't anything this
is a big story
andrew tate banned from facebook and
instagram we love that
lovely
i don't know what this is but they're
coming for his youtube channel now we
discovered youtube is making millions of
dollars in ads placed on videos
promoting violence against women by
notorious tick tock influencer andrew
tay
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram gods yeah i mean you know
again tick tock that's the real one
right right because he's big on tick
tock exactly dude him getting banned on
tick tock would actually be but maybe
this is the beginning you know sometimes
they all kind of that's what happens
right in line when
one of them does it so i was on i tagged
andrew hashtag andrew tate on a tick
tock i made recently
when he was explaining the importance of
drinking water did we show that on the
on the show no we didn't
oh can you pull up my tick tock
but i did andrew tate look how many um
it had like 15 billion videos or 15
billion views
yeah
yeah
yeah and he's a fountain of knowledge uh
i posted this on tik tok
thirsty you're dehydrated i have this
thing where if i ever find myself
thirsty and dehydrated what i do is i
treat the whole bottle at once and the
reason i do this is to rehydrate myself
because the reason i'm thirsty is
yeah i mean this is this is hard hitting
stuff yeah is this part of course in
hustler university maybe it's crazy
because that your tick tock has 1.4
million views
it's like normal knowledge there's
there's one on the h3 podcast account
with like nine million views about
android dates
dude yeah it's kind of crazy how
he just he does draw on the views i
can't lie
for everybody
he's live right now with aidan ross and
he has 120k viewers
that's a lot less though than the first
time he was on his show that's true the
first time he had like 320 000. yeah yep
oh weird it just like instantly dropped
from me oh 110 okay
it's weird you want to call in
aidan's a pussycat [ __ ]
[ __ ]
damn i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
um
tate is on andrew's stream right now let
me pull it up and just see what these
bozos are talking about you know what i
think he may have just left that's why
the views went down yeah he left
you know what happened is um
it's night time over there in romania
and he's got to get in his race car bed
and turn on his uh
paw patrol nightlight
i gotta wind my bugatti watch
for my matching bugatti bed but i
you know it's it's expensive you know
real quick
yeah i mean i don't have any bugatti so
um i can see why they look down on me
why don't you have how much is a bugatti
uh over a million oh is that right yeah
really for the most basic model three
three million dollars two million dollar
car yeah they're expensive seriously
yeah what a waste of money
yeah here's a highlight of their
conversation
yeah
in case you thought you missed anything
interesting
always doing [ __ ] [ __ ]
such a loser bro
i have no respect for this kid anymore
i really don't the cheapest uh
model bugatti is 1.9 million
damn son you are an idiot
what a waste of [ __ ] money yeah and i
mean imagine owning a supercar in like a
metropolis i mean you can't go fast you
can't that's what i wanted to go up
curbs is it even meant for like daily
driving no absolutely no you're not
super cars like that people who want to
drive them they break trucks
to ship them where they're going because
you don't want to put extra miles on the
engine like it is so [ __ ] dumb on one
of these cars i can't yeah it's more of
a show car than anything sure yeah i get
that the upkeep is crazy it says on
average people spend half a million
every four years on upkeep you have to
change the tires so a lot of upkeep on
them yeah i think they're like 30 000 a
piece or something like that also can i
what is so [ __ ] cool about abu like
what can make a car worth two million
dollars i'm sure it's super fun to drive
i'm gonna deny that it's like 2 million
i mean how do you yeah is it worth it
probably not no it's definitely not fast
as [ __ ]
it's hand built the majority of it give
a [ __ ] if it's ham built it goes up to
300 miles per hour it's not for you it's
for 300 miles per hour sure yeah
things go endlessly expensive like you
know it's not it's for like the top of
the top people who really care about all
the details super in the car yeah super
into cars also if you're running away
from the police 300 miles per hour
oh my god it has six exhaust pipes
it's a supercar i have a matching bed
too
wait but how do you put but just
genuinely how do you put two million
dollars of materials it's just up charge
and
i mean it's just a name it's name you
know it's a name brand thing probably
very expensive materials that are that
are strong but lightweight which is why
it's part of why it's so fast too and
you know i'm just you know i'm sure it
costs a lot less than 2 million to
produce but just like any other field
like you can like could tour in fashion
i don't know right all right oil changes
per year 21 000.
what do you do it like every day when
you come back from driving how many oil
changes you're getting that should cost
like 30 bucks at jiffy lube
something tells me you don't take a
bugatti to jiffy lube i don't think so
yeah
but yeah i mean
there's a lot of people pay
five thousand dollars for a t-shirt from
some you know luxury
high high-end fashion label or whatever
and uh kind of the same with cars same
with anything like he was saying
yeah but it's 2 million i mean 5 000 is
like
you can live with that kind of damage
anyway andrew state's an idiot
drive angry and he is oh this speaking
of andrew tate there was like a whole
offshoot story that you guys might be
interested in
um everybody's donating to sam's bugatti
fun now oh [ __ ] you guys have a long way
to go on that i am you're obligated to
get a bugatti now
well andrews is going to be impounded
pretty soon so we might be able to do it
get it cheap
oh
sale
yeah
yep yes so that's great news but
we were actually not even planning to
talk about this but we had a whole
andrew tate story planned and what it is
insurance is 4k a month it's got to be
way more than that
i'm seeing on average this just random
article says that 4k month on average
um
so teachers have been saying that andrew
tate is ruining young men have you heard
this ela
a post on reddit went viral this week
when a middle school teacher said that
the rise of andrew tate is beginning to
ruin her young male students
now this post seems so outlandish
that i almost didn't i have a hard time
even believing it i'll read it to you
guys why i'll read it and then you tell
me
uh there's a the thing is it was
confirmed by another teacher who made a
tick tock which we'll watch afterwards
and she
is like
you can tell she's like a real teacher
she puts her face on and everything but
here you go let me read this
have you all heard of a sexist
misogynist disgusting excuse of a human
being known as andrew tate
well i promise you all of your middle
school and high school boys have
and they're addicted to his content just
this week i've had
six combos with families about their
sons saying [ __ ] like women are inferior
to men when the women belong in the
kitchen
that i mean what the i mean what
boys that age low-key like
i'm sure andrew tate is making it ten
times worse but like boys that age can
be so mean
sure
yeah
not only are they making these
misogynistic claims in class but they're
literally refusing to do assignments if
it's sourced
from a woman i had three boys refused to
read an article by a female author
because women should only be housewives
bro there's no way is that possible that
the kids are saying that [ __ ] it's like
so outlandish i believe it yeah yeah of
course dude they're saying they're like
what you're so impressionable i mean if
they think this guy's cool and this is
the kind of [ __ ] he's saying all the
time
level of [ __ ] misogyny yeah that's
why it's so upset this is like taliban
[ __ ]
i mean
i mean by outside interject but go ahead
okay sorry
my dad is a principal my mom's a special
ed teacher
and they really kind of talk to me about
it like they don't know
andrew take my my name like my dad
mentioned like drew taint as he's
thinking that's the name but
they they've already gotten reports of
like you know young boys from you know
freshmen in high school like saying the
kind of rhetoric that he spews out and
not getting in trouble for it so it's
happening dude what's crazy is these
kids are never going to get any [ __ ]
they're never going to get a date
they're never going to get laid these
kids are demons i mean the girl
young women are not falling for this
[ __ ] are they
this is also just the parents fault
totally in my opinion yeah or well like
other than tate i guess but like
unrestricted access to like tick tock
for a 12 year old [ __ ] dude that's kind
of kind of weird in my opinion yeah
how do you high school kids are more
like
i don't know i don't know but anyway
here actually we looked this up andrew
sent uh this was a leaked picture of his
bet how he sleeps it
it's really comfy that's exactly what i
was picturing and he has the night
lights come out of the headlights it's
really sweet it's safe he feels safe
it's a safe spot getting an oil change
just uh code for he pissed the sheets
and yeah
brother brother i had another oil change
in my sleep
i'm licking coolant
[Music]
please brother i need a new oil change
[Music]
i blew his gasket brother can you bring
me some new boxers
wet dream blew a gasket
oh yes thank you
yeah so um
avery you were saying sorry or someone
was saying something that was me um
yeah yeah i know my dad's a principal
for high school
special ed teacher for like high school
and yeah they've they've heard the
rhetoric and stuff and it's kind of
scary because like it's kind of like
what some people are saying in chat
parents kind of don't really pay oh no
love said it yeah parents don't really
pay attention
and like even if they are they kind of
they kind of don't get this tick tock
[ __ ] and stuff so like they don't really
know how to even look out for it because
they're even aware of it you must not
have any relationship with your parents
to say [ __ ] because like if i heard my
son saying this [ __ ] i'd be like
right
bro i don't know man that would not fly
but you know one of the
when i read the your document so i kind
of know what's coming one of the parents
or two of the parents are like
immigrants so they don't speak english
that well yeah that's tough so they
don't necessarily understand what the
kid is watching
yeah but you think that they would have
a certain values instilled in them from
their [ __ ] family they wouldn't be
overturned by tate in a day but okay
it's happening
it's crazy hard to believe
50 bucks from drew
i need to thank abe for his sizzler
incident
and subsequent heimlich tutorial with
lena my boyfriend was choking on his
food unable to breathe i knew exactly
how to help without panicking whoa we
did it
stay for the life-saving advice
wow look it's okay i know how scared
that is though glenn here he's okay
there you go i knew we would save a life
i said we're going to do this yeah
someone
someone watching is going to get their
life saved so the gift
of it
yeah and i'd be i would just be so
devastated to lose another sub because
we need them
well at the end of the day yeah god
forbid if something happens to one of
them
they can't unsubscribe that's what i
wonder do they get unsubscribed after a
certain level of activity oh it's like
the uh recurring payments thing you
brought up the other day yeah yeah as
long as they don't unsubscribe before
they choke it's all good then there's
something that's true
they're locked in
so anyway
uh not only are they making these yes so
they're they're not doing assignment
source from women i had three boys to
refuse to read an article because women
should only be housewives but when i say
i'm a teacher and i'm here to teach you
the cognitive dissonance kicks in and
they start saying yeah but teaching
is a woman's job
five to six parents all mothers were
mortified when i discussed
their comments
the other one dad said well he isn't
wrong
that's what i'm saying like where are
where do you live i just i can't imagine
that i mean maybe the world is so [ __ ]
up and i'm being naive i just like
seriously a dad saying well they're not
wrong i mean it's just what
we live in a society
i just don't get this
to our immigrant mothers and they cried
on the phone when i shared a video of
andrew tape because their sons kept
referencing and translating the content
to them and this particular video was
talking about his webcaming business i.e
human trafficking women
shout out love that
y'all it's been only two weeks of school
and these young boys are losing it i've
never heard such vitriol from young boys
since andrew tate guy came on the scene
the rise of incel and misogynix stick
rhetoric is terrifying
so what do you i mean i mean you buy all
this
i did when i read it
godly
but i mean not you even have further
yeah with all the other people
corroborating it yeah i feel like it's
probably pretty real i was reading some
of the [ __ ] i had some kids put
this as their role model on the student
info questionnaire this week i was like
do i really want to know who this is
so they were writing down andrew tate
yo
yeah so there's that one but then this
one kind of sealed the deal for me
because i mean there's a face to it and
i mean there's an american flag behind
her where else would would you be about
a classroom right
only [ __ ] psychos and teachers fly
that [ __ ]
uh god bless america though
right like at this day and age if you're
flying an american flag maybe you're a
veteran or you're a service member but
not on a holiday post office post office
you know government buildings whatever
but if you're like a private citizen in
your home
on a normal ass day not near any holiday
no fourth of july no nothing flying
american flag is that that's a red flag
right literally and and and
for real that's a little bit weird about
that i was looking at old photos and i
was wearing a shirt when i was like 13
that had an american flag on it and i
was like whoa and then i was like
oh it wasn't a thing yeah back then as
much as it is now it's like a statement
yeah i mean it was co it was it's
right it's this really [ __ ] up
christian nationalism or
you know so that or white nationalism
they're just like
it's just not a good look the american
flag these days it's not and i i love
america i'm proud to be america we just
don't fly that jet it's weird i feel
like maybe it is everywhere though not
just america like to be in your country
and to be like
got my flag rationalistic kind of weird
no you know when i was a kid
it was like olivia touched on
it was not the same way it was like you
could fly an american flag you could
wear american shirt and it was just fun
i disagree a little bit just
specifically in the period from like
2002 to 2005 during the george bush era
when people got really [ __ ] horny for
going to war
and i remember like everybody was like
rah-rah-rah american flying their flags
around and stuff and at that point it
was starting to get pretty weird just
because people were getting so fervent
and
yeah uh i think before before that
arrows back before 9 11 it was all good
fair enough i'm a little bit older i'll
have to disagree just because i'm arab i
love this country everything about it
pull me an american flag my pajamas our
american flag god bless this country
baby
okay
[Music]
you have to fly an american flag bro
yeah i'm trying to get a visa so i'm not
here for it too
i i also have that side of me maybe
because like
what else is out there not much is
better than america yeah but i agree it
gets harder it gets harder to say that
when now there's like abortions
yeah illegal like what the [ __ ]
yo so i agree i love america like i said
i wouldn't i would rather i wouldn't
rather live anywhere else
that being said
if you are flying an american flag
there's a good chance that uh you might
be blowing up a kindergarten
like a 50 50.
just saying
just saying
anyway i'm just saying what were you
saying lady
yeah the american flag he didn't say
anything yet you just saw a few stripes
of red and white just saying
i gotta speak my mind on it we got three
hours to fill you bro
you know
anyway here
so i'm a teacher and i teach sixth grade
um we've been in school for three days
now and within these three days the
amount of
young 11 year old boys that told me that
they love andrew tate is ridiculous
this man is
really affecting the minds of young men
i had a boy today 11
turn to a girl
and tell her that she's fat
and whatnot you need to be thin
she sits at home and she eats all day
and that she's like every other girl in
the world
and that she uses men
to get money
at least he's a hard-working man and he
works for his 11.
they're 11.
okay
wow you need to be aware of what your
kids are watching because this is
ridiculous and it's really affecting
kids
young kids it's disgusting that's a
strange phenomenon maybe this is gonna
be a good wake-up call for all parents
because i think a lot of parents
you know they're dying for their quiet
time and they see oh he's on youtube
whatever
they're just kind of like they don't
know like how bad it can get on the
internet you know
it gets pretty bad
it's such a weird phenomenon it really
does
there is this massive
in-cell movement happening
red pill movement the manosphere
so i guess it was kind of fertile for
this stuff but he takes it to a level
that
i mean for for a guy to feel brazen
enough like
it's not enough to have your own taste
in women you have to go up to women that
you think aren't living up to their
gender stereotypes and tell them that
they're failing
yeah
i think
for a lot of these kids like we were
saying i mean their brains are they
don't
when you're first hitting puberty you
don't really know who you are you don't
really
have a defined personality yet and
you're just kind of absorbing what's
around you which is why this is bad but
it also means that like i don't know um
not that i'm not pessimistic about this
this is definitely bad but a lot of
these kids will grow out of it i mean
that story that she just told is
evidence of that this kid he literally
doesn't even know what he's saying it's
not even it's not real
it's like i'm a hard-working guy dude
you're 11. you're in middle school you
don't work you don't like you're just
parroting what you heard somebody else
said because you're
desperate to like
figure out who the [ __ ] you are so
hopefully you know
enough people push back on it like you
guys are uh can
push the needle in the other direction
because
you know they don't even know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about they don't
know what they're saying
yeah but it's still i think it still
percolates the i think you're right a
lot of kids will grow up i don't know
what the [ __ ] like you have interest
like when i was 11 i was collecting
troll balls you know what i mean i was
like
just do weird [ __ ] well you know it's
still amazing but like wild
when you
were a young man like not definitely
nowhere to this extent but i remember
there was like always like girls suck
guys are better kind of thing in like
elementary school yeah like girls
yeah exactly like young kids have this
sort of stupid notion girls have that
same
right and there was always a back and
forth but like this is obviously
a significant escalation of that of like
you should work in the kitchen and
you know do my laundry and [ __ ] is
pretty wild for an 11 year old to be
saying so there it is but yeah he's
getting banned everywhere and hopefully
like when alex jones got banned from
everything i think it started with a
couple
and then everyone kind of joined in on
the fun
so hopefully andrew will be banished off
the face of this earth
and also arrested by the fbi soon after
yeah
locked in the dungeon without a key
delete delete him
perish
let him perish
okay
um
hey you guys know pork boy right
we also have he was doing a pizza review
right tell me what you think
here this guy asked him to do a
hairline rating he has something to rate
his hairline
now
is he a fan of the show or have i
created
i'm behind this right i mean nobody was
raiding hairlines before me
come up to me let me be part of review
let me do this he says something that's
never been said he goes wanna do a
hairline review you're doing your pizza
review
yeah get a hairline rating i'll take my
hat off or you got a [ __ ] up hairline
or something yeah i do all right fine
yeah i'm expecting one of the worst
hairlines i've ever seen from this dude
he's got a hat on he's like keep in mind
i'm 21. this better be so bad i lose my
breath
you know when you walk around be like
boy i got a hairline for you
that's a review i love that man owning
it but is that a fan of the show i mean
who goes up and says rape my hairline
yeah i do want to give it to me i'll
take my credit now no i don't think so
what
no
i've never heard
such a thing dave fortner even says
himself never been asked this
i mean
there's only one way to find out
somebody's got to find that guy and ask
him
right
his hairline is pretty incredible though
i'll say that
yeah i'm just flexing on y'all by the
way somebody mentioned that it might be
thin here because the hair is lighter
here so i like that
we i had an existential crisis do you
think it's thinning here a little bit
um no
because it goes up really far we were
yeah i looked back way back like when
you had shaved
here back in israel and you have a
slight
slightly higher on that side show me
even back then whoa i love that love is
always getting doing the research oh
well i mean
i
i was you know the lighting that episode
was a little bit bad so i had to like
double check and nope nothing had
changed hold on i got to see i got to
see yeah there's lots of me with my
shaved head back then
right damn you really think it moved
back
that's crazy no no i don't think so i'm
saying it wasn't always life
you're saying it was yeah it was never
as perfect as you break my hairline dave
portnoy
yeah okay let me know what you see
also this uh concerns you love
you told us that suman strowman aka fika
fish
nobody actually ate it there
right
hold on here's my hair okay i know what
you're going to show this is yeah it's
the same
yeah it's a little it's a little higher
here right
yeah it's always been a little bit
higher on that side
don't worry dude hold on did i
was this when i
dyed my hair or is my hair really that
dark
it could be
coming off of that yeah
because when did we do that
there was a point where we dyed my hair
black first that was in vegas
that was in vegas but i'm just tripping
out if this is my real hair color back
then did we go to vegas after new york
or before new york before
so yeah
could be
but that's like a fresh cut
um
right it's but it looks like it's the
longer parts that are black
yeah so this concerns you love you um
all right
you said nobody eats sumo stroma you're
trying to defend the swedish people but
there is a day
yesterday called sumstromming day
okay
and
and furthermore
there's been a there's been a
light fishing year
and people are clamoring
they're fighting
shoulder to shoulder
hand to hand
brothers sisters fighting at battle over
the sumo strumming it's civil war in the
grocery store watch
it's like black friday yeah
look at that you guys can't get enough
of it what is going on love
look at this what is it look at that man
those deals must be insane that guy's
feet are up
no way yeah this is real
this is funny that this is
this is pandemonium in uh sweden
compared to like
the videos of walmart on black friday
where people are [ __ ] fighting and
throwing each other on the ground
man people are crazy about suman stroman
in sweden
go ahead tell me what i'm missing
read whatever is one of those on one of
those counts a little bit closer oh that
says lux bro lux as says lux wait what
is that that [ __ ] is
what's the orange fish now again that
jumps off the stream salmon smoked
salmon that is salmon guys some of them
were strumming but most of them were
salmon really that's what you're saying
fake news this [ __ ] is soon
look here that says zoom strowman dude
that was just that was just something i
randomly saw now but hold on hold on
yeah but yeah that was just a sign point
side point i just saw but look at all
these boomerangs people dude they're all
boomers not one person under the age of
40.
dude but this is these people are you're
i'm worried about the people of sweden
this [ __ ] these people are mentally ill
i don't know what to say no they just
have like dilapidated ass [ __ ] taste
you know this is a young man
that dude is the that that dude and that
girl in the back there are pretty young
but look at all these other
and look how many he's got
he's sick in the head bro what can i say
i am not
saying anything else in here is this a
really good deed uh deal 114 swedish
crooner
i mean that seems a little bit like
overpriced in my opinion that's like 14
bucks because there's a there's a
shortage right love
i read i read in some ways and there was
a shortage this year because uh there's
not enough fish along the coast
the only reason i hear about serious
drumming ever is because people tagged
me and stuff
and apparently like one of the major i
think the off sketch one that the one
that you guys had i think that one like
actually like went bankrupt that company
oh no
yeah
no i mean
listen to me i do not pretend there's
some crazy people in sweden who eat that
[ __ ] and uh it's like maybe one percent
less than one percent likes that and
they're all boomers look at them they're
fighting
i mean this is concerning me this this
is a concern i'm worried about sweden
yeah look at this look at his feet
is uh is there a food shortage in sweden
this is like the apocalypse are they
just hungry
i don't know these [ __ ] boomers are
just [ __ ] rabbit or something i guess
rabbit suits throbbing boomers i found
an article about it but it's in swedish
and google translate has a very strange
interpretation of the major acid
streaming shortage ahead
the government must introduce measures
look at that big old fistful of [ __ ]
nasty ass [ __ ]
bro
i'm translated then i can translate it
uh let's see here doggins new yetter
biggest substrumming shortage uh before
premiere
uh the government has to
put like uh
what's called measures yeah the
government must act translation yeah
make sure there's enough zoom strumming
for everybody
yeah as a it's a national emergency they
don't
forget about coving maybe all those old
people are like hypebeast they're all
gonna flip that on stockx
i bet they are they have all the [ __ ]
old people home at the and like resell
that [ __ ] yeah
translate substroman as acid fish yeah
that was much
that's a whole different experience
yeah i don't know this girl is young man
i'm just saying yeah she is concerningly
young
she's shopping for the grandparents all
right it's possible yeah there you have
it though okay
shortage here
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll put up some money if one of the
mods wants to hit that okay
i'm gonna take you with food and stuff
but i feel like if i try i'm gonna
probably fail so
kind of a little bit of cash up front
you know what i'm saying
bro it's so bad you can't even it's
indescribable
with me trying and failing for a little
bit of that cash and then maybe like if
i complete it then maybe a bigger
cashbot i mean i'm not it's all it's all
or not ray kevin anybody yeah small
enough interested in the challenge i i
think because i'm sitting really close
to zach something is telling me that i
need to do this
i don't want to do this
kevin scoot over a little bit so i can
see we can see her face hello yeah so
you're serious about this
yeah
oh [ __ ] and you think you could put one
of these down
no
but i still might want to do it no
because ian's the key the stream
strowman keeper you're the only one who
has put down a whole fish
oh no i feel bad do anyone late we're
having our mods here i just see some
people yeah yeah these are our wonderful
mods um ian do you have any advice for
kevin stepping up to this challenge yeah
don't
yeah i mean it's just going to be a mess
we're pretty sure ethan's rash was that
yeah i get a rash every time i [ __ ] yeah
there's only one way to find out i think
i did this
everyone in here would have to deal with
the smell too so yeah that's why i mean
and then well let me ask this ray are
you interested in stepping up to this
i'm willing to try
a bite
but i feel like i'm gonna puke like as a
heads up like i'm pretty certain that i
will puke sam
okay yeah that's a courtesy if they do
it i'll do it oh
yeah this is supposed to be mod
appreciation day
[ __ ] humiliation i love the thought
of us all going to zach's show tonight
smelling like fika fish
we should open it at the show oh
yeah save it for that we should we
should like mosh and open it the grand
finale by the way um
yeah zach is doing a sold out show
tonight oh
viper room baby
viper
can be sick
are you gonna get a matching car to
yours to your watch one day
yeah exactly by the way i want to thank
some people a prolapsed penguin 20
gifted something for gifted
hundred bucks from dave for sam's jeep
fun
still still stacking up bills for that
ethan thank you
bugatti fun uh 50 subs thank you yes
thank you thank you
uh drew gave 50 bucks uh oh this is one
we already read ab saved your life
that's excellent
sam says thank you for the gifted
remember a long time viewer the past two
months i've been the hardest of my life
and had to put down my cat who was my
whole world lost my jobs and friends i
had to drop out because i couldn't
afford tuition the pod saved my life
sam
this is why we're here
love you strong yeah see on monday
now but stick around it'll it's gonna be
it's gonna get better it always does it
really always does
but i'm sorry you lost your cat that's
just i can i
i'd be in shambles if i lost one of our
dogs
anyway speaking of loss uh so you guys
want to do strom
strong uh
we need to do our ad
all right we're way over
so let's do that and then you guys take
a time to think about if you really want
to do this okay if we're doing it we
have to do it at the end because we
can't be in here after we open good
points
we also have food coming and we have to
eat oh [ __ ] so
maybe this is
horrible you guys should not do it i we
can't afford to lose
our mods dude yeah yeah
we've got to get rid of that last can
like someone needs to get it out of the
office because it's going to be brought
up hold on until someone eats it
do you see the super chat
um
[Music]
dorit and mauricio
from the housewives of beverly hills are
apparently having an affair
what
wait wait having an affair dorate and
mauricio
wait wait what what
that's
awesome
wait wait wait we okay we gotta look
into that after the show i don't think
people are super into this housewives i
know that's why i i i could that is
nobody cares about it here but like whoa
that's two of the housewives
significant others
i'm gonna be doing some digging tonight
whoa you guys yeah but so regarding the
sumstromming the fika fish i just find
it endlessly interesting seeing people's
first reaction to it because
you can't fathom how [ __ ] gross it is
you just can't until you're confronted
with it the last time we opened the can
um
the security we opened it in the
alleyway and security thought there was
a dead animal yeah
it smells like a dead animal and we took
it and we took out the
fish and everything at that time he
thought the whole day there was a dead
animal it just lingered
i feel like it's like a rite of passage
in a way
that is true i mean we've all been there
let me thank our sponsor and then we can
take a poll and see what the people
think
you know
anyway thank you to hello fresh we love
them you know them
god bless them
[Music]
yes with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hella fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why folks it's number one
america's number one meal kit what is
that
cheesy back black bean enchiladas
stop
that looks insanely good
oh my god
these are all pictures submitted from
our fupa troopers
uh we love hella fresh what is hello
fresh well
you're gonna be making a home-cooked
delicious recipes that
you really can't mess up they send you
exactly what you need they send this
really cool info card along with it
and
they take you through it step by step
how to make this perfect
delicious and healthy meal
i love it man
uh and also you if you guys are lucky
you might get this one recipe
oh here it is
yeah a burrito
wow
it's a mystery inside you don't know
what the filling is
give it a slow pan over that that is the
burrito of the ages my friend
we go deeper
yeah can we get some oh my god i don't
know if i already made this joke is that
mother mary and the grill mark is that
jesus in the grill mark you have made
that joke whatever you want it to be
it's a banger though
thank you
yeah look at those grill marks boy
yeah that's abs burrito it's an old
timey joke
[Music]
heading out for one last vacation update
your delivery address and enjoy
hellofresh at your vacation destination
well it's fun plans are flexible
flexible and so they work with your
changing schedule this looks bomb dude
that looks so good all of them
uh here's my favorite thing listen hello
fresh is 72 cheaper than dining at a
restaurant and it's even cheaper than
grocery shopping that's money back in
your pocket because you know they send
you exactly what you need you don't have
to buy a whole
bushel of carrots just because you need
two
it's outrageous
the big carrots got us in a stranglehold
enough already
um
go to hellofresh.com afterdark16 and use
the code afterdark16 for 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three
free gifts that's hellofresh.com after
dark 16 use the code afterdark16
for 16 free gifts that's america's
number one meal kit hello fresh thank
you thank you peace and love
peace and love
man i got a headache
when i have migraines coming i get like
this pressure right here and i know
exactly what it's from the my stupid
[ __ ] car
it has a glass roof which you think is
dope right
but
i used to come to work in the middle of
the day where the sun is right overhead
now it's tinted
but it's still right in my eye so i'm
squinting the whole ride and if i don't
have a hat or something to cover my face
it's just horrifically
there's no like um no no covering no on
there
interesting i mean it's like super
tinted right so it doesn't have one that
does no it doesn't have anything right
the new cards they like kind of like
forgot about that old thing because it's
ugly but you don't need it the tesla
doesn't have a
it's got a cover either shitty one yeah
you could you could probably add another
layer of um tint on there if you take it
to a tin shop and that that might help
it
oh god my head do you want and
tylenol
a coffee
or a coke zero i want all of those how
about some sort strawmen everything
above and some strumming
um oh yeah i'll take an advil thank you
guys oh wait i can't thailand tylenol
yeah if you don't have it it's fine i
believe we have a teddy fresh if we
don't have here it's not a big deal i
don't think
but anyway i want to turn to the chat do
you guys think the mod should do this
and vote you know
i agree if we do it we should do it at
the end of the show
right
because it's going to be stinky yes yes
but i do think like do the people want
to see this do they want to put the
monster this it's true that it's a
uh
rite of passage
right
the mod delegation has came together and
discussed it and after much
consideration of your proposal we are
down
wow okay so you guys are wanting to do
this i think it's like iconic
you know
so here's what i'm thinking it's show
history i gotta say
because as as
mentioned you know we have zach's show
tonight
all three of you will be burping
fish for the next like 12 hours
will happen that's just so you know
maybe maybe for further consideration
it's not just fish you understand it's
not burping the taste of fish which is
gross enough it's far far worse your
breath will smell like a dead animal oh
yeah it's not worth it like honestly
guys it's it's really not worth it and
you guys are probably
going to meet a lot of people at the
show
and the chat is not that hyped well
let's do a poll do a poll i actually
expected them to be really
juicy
well we have a scientific way of
determining this should the mods should
the mods do it or is it a bad idea do
the fika or no fika yes vika no fika
yes speaker
no fika how was that about i'm just
being slow
[Music]
and this this isn't a criticism but it's
just an observation that you guys have
committed a
classic rookie mistake of not
negotiating the dollar amount well we
haven't even discussed that that's what
i'm saying you all agreed to it before
i'm just i'm just saying yeah well i
mean ethan did offer money so that
hasn't i didn't say how much he
once we get the chats you know chat is
disgusting
that is very against this oh it's a no
come on chad give us a little bit of
bread chat is not for it
that's surprising me too yeah if you
guys want to see this you better get
those votes in
chat chat see i'm like with ethan i'm
kind of curious too to see because like
what i love about the fika fish segment
you guys do
is like the various people's reactions
and stuff and like and like i don't know
when i was here i was low-key curious i
was like yo
i understand the curiosity but you you
just you don't you know what you're
signing up for you really don't i mean
chat's got your best interest in mind
you know so i read it i read an
interesting suggestion open it let them
smell it
because
you know yeah we could just do the smell
once you smell it you'll understand
better what it is you're doing yeah it
seems like good compromise
yeah
yeah and the smell is arguably worse
than the actual taste itself too right
like that's what ian says yeah that is
not
okay
yeah i never ate it myself as long as i
don't touch it i shouldn't get a rash
yeah yeah yeah
so keep it away from me
i think it's funny though honestly i
like it's horrific but i think it's
funny when it's around i just having a
good time man
i think i'd like to have a party where
you just open the feed go and close the
doors hot box
it's a fun thing it's like the ultimate
senior prank exciting
in in sweden we i i don't think anyone
open it inside but also we open it in a
bucket under water right um yeah and
that way
you you won't have that like pop and
it won't smell at all actually what if
we try it
so you rinse it off like no the smell is
why we're opening it
yeah
i'm just saying like it it's not as bad
as you'd think when you like rinse it
sure i would never use it anyways we
have donations coming in from chelsea
paying the mods not to eat it ladies and
gentlemen
[Laughter]
well i mean how much is chelsea yeah so
how much money how much money you want
smell it and then tell me how much money
you want to eat it you have to eat a
whole [ __ ] fish bro who wants
to lose some money [ __ ]
you know you got to go in you got to do
the end you know if i'm smelling them
down i'm down dude i'm committed to the
cost
avery will be good because he's six
eight he's not breathing anyone's face
he's staying above everyone so
you won't even know yeah i kind of want
to open it right now i'm not going to
lie
dude we will have to sit in it for the
rest yeah we're only an hour ahead of
the show yeah the misery is what the
funny grand finale that's what's funny
about that i'm i'm i'm with ethan
it's for the time payment value right
yes yeah think of the show
not fun
by the way the poll is tightening
should the mods do the fika if you if
yes takes over the 50 mark we're opening
that right now
chad i am so surprised you said no i'm
so surprised chat me too
yes for sure
chad is never predictable
you're
beautiful
if you vote no if you vote if you vote
yes you drink you're a grown-up you
don't drink water yeah
sleep in a big coffin
all people voted no instead of hitting
no why don't you hit that subscribe and
like button
okay player love that
love that for you it's 50 50. in fact
it's yes fika times on top no it's not
uh
i thought i heard
a music drop like well yeah and then i
don't know what happens yeah you get me
all hyped up on the fortnite thing and
then
that wasn't not that one
what are you talking about
let me speak
let me speak
shut up talk about the allegations i
unblocked
i i unblocked blowbee
unblocked bobby
[Music]
no i'm not on twitter so that's why i
actually do online blocking don't tell
anybody but
i don't answer dm's to anybody so bring
that [ __ ] tan boys the fika is on top
51.49 500 subs
this is happening the mods you guys are
getting the true h3 experience
you guys wanted to come visit this is
your fault
so why is it coming to us
give it here do you guys not want to do
it outside like i said sitting down
so we're down to doom because i know
someone earlier suggested smelling it
and then you know going for it i'm we're
down to compromise and do that it's
actually a really beautiful uh can it's
up to you guys yeah we shouldn't touch
it talk about how pretty
we shouldn't we shouldn't mess it is
like why is it like bulging out that's
what's so [ __ ] horrific i didn't like
the noise when you shook it either not a
good noise yeah
also that can is uh surprisingly good at
holding the smell in there it doesn't
really tell me that no it's nothing
until so until the top what concerns me
about strowman is the canned bulges and
you're always taught don't eat it if
it's bulging like that's uh what do you
call that and there's a botulism there's
a dent
but this is what it this is what it's
supposed to look like
well we were talking about yesterday
with hassan that one channel that eats
uh like
canned [ __ ] from the war yeah this is
kind of like that i guess yeah
right
all right you guys can still back out
mods all three of you guys have
conversed
this is my nightmare what's the what's
the chat pole as it's still 50 50.
they're way up yeah i know we got the
yes well then we have to do it yeah we
got all right so here's how it's gonna
work guys we're gonna open it right here
on the desk because this is my idea so i
have to suffer through it and then you
guys are gonna come up one by one
put your nose right in it get a good
whip
and then you can each decide
individually
how much
if you want to proceed with eating one
of these
how much would you like
and we can negotiate on a price okay
my god but
wait what happened can opener
i think it was maybe one of you guys out
or something yeah the the look
of a shock on everyone's face looking
for this can opener
wait how do we know don't stab it
suspicious activity in the office yo
olivia did you hide that can opener no i
didn't get it i didn't get it i wanted
that because they they're gonna be like
oh it was just being paranoid but i'm
like dude someone hid that [ __ ] for sure
by the way a.b i wanted to ask you
because you thought um
what's his name julian you thought he
was trolling us but he wasn't
yeah he wasn't i was wrong okay
there was a decent shot as he would have
though but he was coming he was like
we're being trolled we're being trolled
i thought it was very possible
the dude's a twitch streamer he didn't
know how to use
his uh his camera that's a good point we
found it
okay everybody i wonder the doctor
you guys have and also it's less of a
gotcha if one of us is like this is a
troll for sure and then it ended up
being a troll right that's just this is
safe he wanted to be that guy right okay
so we're gonna have to get a shot here
um okay so this is happening guys you
guys have no idea we have pizza on the
way too by the way we don't wanna been
near this when we've done it or
elaborate i don't think i've ever done
anything this is good this is exciting
this is part of the legacy of this show
well
this is the end of the other ethan why
don't you let one of us open it i i feel
like you shouldn't you shouldn't touch
it yes
um we'll do it live yeah yeah
but do it on the desk but maybe i won't
open it yeah
yeah
i break out and then crazy ass lives
and i start living on uh
we should see it we should
not yet
all right the mod mods come come let's
do this okay god speed kevin i want you
guys to see i want you guys to really
know what you're getting yourself into
if you guys are doing snacks or drinking
enjoy it now
because
when is the pizza arriving dan
well that's okay
all right so mods
[Music]
yeah that's a good idea kim
so this is one innocent can of of fish
so once again for
for everybody at home and you guys
behind me we're gonna open the can yeah
you guys will take one by one you will
take a deep
deep smell close proximity because i
want you all to know what you're getting
yourselves in
and one by one will negotiate on a price
to consume a whole fish because once
you're you know they say
once you're in the trenches taking
grenades then the war the reality of war
i'd catch a grenade for you you would
i'll need that i'll call on that for you
all right wait okay so here we go so
here we go and then also get a shot of
ela because she hasn't
you might want to back up move your
stuff away from it that's because it's
oh i got some on my hand
can we wait wait can we put a towel can
we put a towel down wait is
[Music]
why didn't you put a towel
down that's a juicer
so the smell is hitting them
the smell is hitting them
they didn't know what they were getting
themselves i didn't stop
oh my god i don't know what the big deal
is what are you guys talking about well
yeah like you were halfway across the
world though
i i wanted to all right
yeah so again once that smell hits you
oh my god it's over here you understand
the situation you're in babylon
avery are you you in or out it's okay if
you want to bail at the or no sorry uh
uh sorry not avery
[Music]
yeah well let's get a look at it
somebody's got to open it oh my god it's
over here now dude maybe did you yeah
baby ran to the bathroom and puked
shredder seems very intrigued by the
smell
actually where's where's uh alfredo uh
he dipped man oh he's chilling he's on
face shredder is interested though
ab i just want to give a shout out who
opened it and it squirted on me
on my phone
are you out what happened we got to open
this thing oh
someone else
just be careful on the edge there i
don't want to just fall
you got to fish that top cover out i
think yeah shredder's trying to get her
by it he's sniffing around
someone needs to go ahead and put their
finger in there
stick your finger
so
somebody you
kevin and avery are feeling pretty
confident about this
can you just push it in a little bit
away from the edge yeah thank you
[Music]
avery you out
no avery says he's unbothered by it
yes wait oh god
that one's real slushy eh yeah that
doesn't look safety why is that what's
so slushy this one is a different cut
leave a fork
so we could dip so you guys could see
we have to throw that table out man
what are you doing
wait show ela so i didn't know how bad
it was gonna be i really didn't it's um
it's like you guys were not kidding
that's what i'm saying it's like it
starts like a fart but then it's like a
fart from a dead animal come get a
close-up on this ian if you could takes
over or dance space
you can't you don't understand it until
you smell the space is big and it
oh my god
kevin you [ __ ] mad man
bro when you start sloshing around you
unlock new smells
back up dude you're not you're getting
ahead of yourself i can't look at that
shot you guys
bubbling it's bubbling percolating
oh my god
oh i'm negotiating i'm i'm discussing my
camera now
don't discuss with cam i'm the money man
well
you know you know he's he's my friend
you know my mod is here and you know all
right avery come here yeah yeah avery
i'm talking
okay okay guys come come come
all right kevin you seem the most amped
up here so all right everybody focus
we're get we're gonna do this now okay
now hold on hold on what i want you to
do before
dip your finger in a little bit just a
little dunk and then smell your finger
yeah and then smell your finger
stick your finger up to your nose
yes so once if you can eat it after that
then you're good to go but i i you need
to understand what you're doing i don't
i think you need to do that too i
understand okay what do i do so you
could sit back can we get some paper
towels that wasn't important so avery
dip your finger in there
holy [ __ ] bro
did stip dip a finger in there okay
oh we need a not a mica to paper towels
dip it in there real good come on so i'm
going to hold that mic so we can hear
you i mean this is enough
no whoa
i didn't say taste it bro i said smell
it you went for the taste
you need you need a t you want to wipe
your hands or you got something
yo homie you went for the taste oh i'm
not supposed to say oh [ __ ] was i not
supposed to taste it well you well you
could do it but your that was that was
wow dip your finger in it smell it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah put it right up to
your nose
yeah
it smells like
wow i know my dad's fart smell worse
dude oh
my god this guy has been
whoa
it does smell but it's like oh it's kind
of baby [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie i'm not
trying to front it what did it taste
like when you licked your finger it
smells like
i don't know we'll try again
oh my god this is king [ __ ] right here
oh my god it's like
someone put
salt in like
like i was bullied as a kid so i
accidentally tasted dog turd once but
like
well like sorry about that no that's all
good you know [ __ ] bakersfield but
you know i
yeah it's not
is it better to season your dog [ __ ] or
not well you know i i didn't like want
to taste it it was kind of forced upon
me either no i'm saying yeah yeah you
know yeah yeah i'm probably for for a
season you know if you have to do
something like that um it tastes like
beef jerky yeah let's look at this dude
again you can bail at any time i just
need you to dunk a finger in
and give it a sniff okay
can you guys talk in the mic this
doesn't give us anything all right every
year
no this is this doesn't get you anything
this is to just so you if
to see if you're up for this because if
you can't even smell it then
yeah so go ahead dunk your finger in
nails i'm gonna do a knuckle yeah that's
fine that's fine oh my god that's fine
yeah she dunked it go ahead it's pretty
bad but i you know i think i can do it
oh my god
you guys are machines
now let's negotiate for all three of you
so all three of you guys are wanting to
do this
oh okay okay
right you're all you're in you're all in
no to this huge piece
okay so baby can you fish out some sizes
we can do some size comps here
just find like a
you'd have to use your fingers you
savage
do you want me to do it for you
i can do it for you i mean yeah you guys
gonna have to eat a whole strip of that
[ __ ]
and by the way by the way what ian did
was a way where she ate a whole one with
the tail on and he had to spit out bones
and crack
[ __ ]
so that's easy you just throw that [ __ ]
back
right ian i mean
oh [ __ ]
so where do you guys want us where are
you guys starting on this
be reasonable be reasonable
three thousand dollars
who's gonna say i'm not grand i'm not
giving you each a grand
500
500 500
no but the thing is you gotta eat it
oh yeah yeah if i fail i don't get
anything and i don't want to feel bad if
you guys fail okay i don't want none of
this give him the money nonsense
find by me
all right i'll give you each 500 bucks
i'm in to sit down
it tastes like jerky
you can vomit if you want i don't care
yeah i won't
i won't hold it in your body against
your will
all right so um
why don't you start fishing out a piece
and i'll tell you if it's approved or
not okay so you got to find a whole full
chunk
at least reaction this or maybe
yeah so that chance what yeah yeah
that's that's great that's perfect
all right so hold on love has love you
wanted to make a comment
usually that's slushy oh yeah
all right avery five hundred dollars you
gotta down that
all right yeah good luck brother all
right see it's fifty 50 either i'm gonna
do it or i'm gonna have to run the
bathroom y'all ain't coming on the show
later man because i'm like a piggy eater
so you know oh you're a picky eater yeah
so it's like you don't like it or don't
but then i eat some weird what's your
favorite food oh i love pizza but then i
also come with weird food combos like
like cereal ketchup and milk are you
breathing through your nose or mouth
right now
nose oh my god
why should i breathe in my mouth
no i can't breathe through my nose all
right [ __ ] faint
yeah okay so avery's going for it we got
a good shot of this so first we'll do
the taste test if i like it you're gonna
give it a little suckerino a little
sucko
avery gave it a little taste off the
back there nibbling on a on it see most
people i would think would just go for
it and down it but you went for a little
flavor truck i can't chug [ __ ] so it's
like i have to take my time it's a curse
but
well do people do say it's good to chew
your food
not zoom and stroma necessarily okay
let's keep going
oh you're going to take it in bites
yo avery is taking it in bites this is
on we have never seen this strategy play
out before slow and steady wins the race
this man took a nibble
this is this is unprecedented
how are you feeling avery it's more
salty it tastes like the ocean no okay
yeah it's just like kevin howard's
kevin's walking off are you okay kevin
are you gonna yeah you're okay okay okay
there's a bus there's a bathroom am i
going to have a soda no no no okay well
i'm not going to wash it you can watch
it okay can someone get like a coke for
me or something sure yeah
i'll have a drink on standby for you
he's taking a second bite this split
this has never played out like this this
man is going to spend take four bites on
this
this is unbelievable
yeah it's like it's like ocean water you
know i recognize there's the sink in
there but i don't know it's because like
i you know i lived in my dad until i was
like 18 so you know smell those nasty
ass farts or whatever
or you know my stomach is iron i gotta
meet your dad dude they're like this
one day ethan
something is wrong with that guy's farts
no
oh they're they're nasty that is the
third fight from avery i've never this
is totally unprecedented i've never seen
i never imagined
they're saying you're mega king
holy [ __ ]
cool all right
i don't want to waste more time but so
yeah just just knock it out everyone's
like oh
oh my wavery
yeah
okay that one maybe i should have done
in different ways but i can do it it's
too big you should find it very chewy
uh-oh
no no no uh-oh does he have trouble with
the last bite
which is more like it's like it just
wants to stay in there you know
right yeah you really just slosh it
around in there huh
it tastes like beef jerky
does it taste like beef jerky
oh god all right avery go to the
bathroom you succeeded wash your hands
don't touch me please
oh my god what a king oh my god
i cannot [ __ ] believe what i just saw
this man
is not human
actually
which one's up next
who's feeling it
all right ray is up next have a seat
please ray
holy [ __ ]
how are you feeling
uh i'm feeling pretty good i'm about to
make some money okay 500 bills yeah
okay
so let's get fish out a nice chunk for
us if you would please
okay
um
[Music]
avery set the bar pretty high he did oh
wait there we go i feel like that's kind
of vile but not you know what it's on
the light side but i'll let it i'll let
it slide
yeah of course
yeah i got you all right i'm just gonna
take it like that's what i would do you
know taking it in chunks is pretty
psychotic but okay so um
ray are you ready
let's get this [ __ ]
all right get paid
write it write down the hats
right down the hatch
i don't see any chewing it's just subtle
it swallowed it you can do that
oh my god
you didn't chew it at all how did you do
that i just swallowed like i don't know
i just oh my god chew that [ __ ]
yo
wait that's cheating spit it out
man that fish is swimming in her stomach
right now uh-oh how do you feel you feel
something i just taste it now right
that's what's killing me like i can
taste the
it's not even like like salt like what
mega was describing it literally just
tastes like ass like it's really bad it
tastes like jerky does it taste like
beef jerky no i wish no no
do you guys have like toothbrushes or
mouthwash
we actually do yeah sam has sam cook you
up yeah you do have a stereo go clean
yourself off uh ray is about two very
different approaches
two very different approaches
i was like
how she do that all right now kevin
i didn't see how big ray's piece was you
gotta ask look for
word no no no yeah we're looking for
avery sizes
let's see so you show it to me and i'll
prove it i want less skin
so kevin is fishing for his dream that's
that's what i'm thinking i believe in
you kevin kevin is fishing for his dream
bite let me see
that's perfect man that's all you buddy
oh boy are you to go in with the fork
you're going to go with the fork like
it's a scrumptious [ __ ] bite of
mashed potatoes or something it tastes
like beef jerky just it tastes like
it tastes like kevin you're going in
with the fork chewing it up kevin is
chewing with the fork oh the bucket's
right here
not happening oh my god oh my god
it's so soft
it's so salty
oh
i'll give you the opportunity to take a
smaller one kevin i believe in you man
because i don't want to leave you out
but yeah thank you for that ginger ale
that i brought yeah go ahead you know
clear your palate it tastes like beef
jerky i gotta say it did not taste like
beef jerky it was pretty beast going in
with the fork i don't know why but that
made it kind of gnarly for me like
eating a ravioli hey no 11 in the chat
no
no all right so i'll give you the
opportunity kevin
to go in for a smaller piece i don't
want to leave you out of course so let's
see
i mean if it doesn't happen you were so
close you were so close you were chewing
so much chewing
what was going on in your mouth that
made you abort it was just so salty
so salty interesting like
if you were to pour a bunch of salt in
the water it's just salt yeah oh ocean
water yeah yeah all right let's find a
nice scrump just a little morsel can i
do like half of this one let me see
sure sure yeah you cut that in half if
it even kind of try like gray try to
swallow it i don't know how she did i
can't do that well i worry that if it
goes down it's going to come back up
so this is a much smaller delicacy and
if you can get that down then you can
join the players club
i don't know i don't know the royalty
club you got this kevin
let's go you got this buddy you got it
kevin kevin okay he's got it he's trying
to get it down he's sloshing it around
oh [ __ ]
this ain't right
it's not going to happen guys
don't do it i tried i tried the race
strategies oh yeah that was worse
[Music]
[Music]
kevin kevin kevin i'm giving you 50
bucks for that bro you got 50 bucks i'm
pledging you 50 bucks hold on ela are
you up uh
you're up elo no way in in in
just no way 500 bucks ela
absolutely i can't i can barely breathe
here i can barely keep my eyes open all
right listen you know what
i think he still gets yeah he gets the
money i can't say no you said you took a
second effort you really tried your best
yeah it does it does andrew tate would
say it's definitely an experience like
wow that's not at all what i expected
okay i need to step away for a minute
can i have some help cleaning this up
because i can't touch any of this [ __ ]
clean this up real quick okay guys
here i'll sit at one of your computers
and i can talk from that
you know there's like an aftertaste bro
is that normal
you know it doesn't taste bad but like
it's
uh it's like it's like kind of wish uh i
can't even imagine what your stomachs
feel like right now oh it feels fine i'm
chilling
i just noticed my breath kind of smells
so it's like how's this
is this good ian yeah that's interesting
oh i'm in the commander's seat this is
pretty dope
is this what it feels like to be dan
i feel powerful
are you growing to like the um scorpion
chair dan
no i hate it oh [ __ ] dad hates the
scorpion chair i'm i'm telling you it's
telling you olivia it's clear to come
back up no one else is going to puke
thank you to uh lena and sam
okay and a b of course
you threw themselves valiantly
anytime into into battle
any time
incredible to apologize to av hila and
uh olivia and anyone else feeling the
mood right now you guys voted for this
okay dude you know the [ __ ] olivia
olivia's spot looks like she's
evaporated her macbook was on the floor
wide open all of her bag is like open
stuff is everywhere yeah
yeah oh when people start yakking she
freaks out right yeah
yeah she's been on the parking lot the
other [ __ ] up thing is a b handed abe
handed out masks for us but the thing is
the mask smelled like the [ __ ] face
yeah that map isn't going to help
anything
it's the smell in the air man it's not
going to do anything
how are you ray
okay so everyone's doing good i keep
smelling my breath
there's a mouthwash in the bathroom
okay yeah kevin or avery if you want
huh oh i'm fine to be honest like
like i chew pills when i take medication
because i can't swallow well and that
tastes way worse than like you don't
even want to use mouthwash
do we have mouthwash i'll take that
because yeah we do we do okay cool let
me do that you know i think it's not a
bad idea
you don't want people on the street
getting a whiff of that
you know
oh my god
dan is dual wielding uh air fresheners
well why would you do that to him
he's been through enough dan
[Music]
anyone here hell is rating radiating off
of a b
i think flushing it is a good way to get
rid of it yeah yeah yeah yeah do you
guys want to flush it essential oil
diffuser over there too
so we are uh in cleanup mode here guys
bear with us
ethan do you want the uh essential oil
diffuser on the desk
i'm blown out vanilla and does it shoot
out clorox
i don't know what that is
[Music]
yeah so do we have the windows open and
stuff guys
yeah kevin i love you man but you stink
now can now who wants to smell avery's
breath
how much you give me
i can't breathe i can't see the
toothbrush or anything have you done
have you done the mouthwash yet avery
nah okay so cam how much you want to get
get a nice whiff of his breath 100 bucks
okay done okay but wait wait wait wait
wait wait jesus chick abraham
going for it so you gotta open your
mouth avery and just a big old exhale
right onto his nose all right and you
got to breathe deep cam okay
i want my value for that i'm going to
earn my money one big boy i know how to
breathe all right
you guys do a countdown and then we'll
and a couple breaths a couple breaths
not just one you gotta live in that
space love can you count down from uh 10
in swedish sure yeah that sounds great i
might have forgotten how to do that but
i'll try
three are we ready okay
see you
near you wait wait not yet start not yet
okay look go ahead go ahead
[Laughter]
hey closer all right all right
dude i'm gonna puke i'm gonna puke i
always swear to god
stop stop stop stop stop
wow dude how was that cameron
[Applause]
sam do you have a
spare toothbrush or something i couldn't
find any
five bucks oh samson yeah that's gonna
cost you hundred bucks buddy
hey cam how was that
brutal with you know peace and love it's
it's just the feeka fish but
i can't hear you bru it was brutal yeah
brutal
oh brother
my headache is worse
the tsum strumming how you know from
sona it's coming on now you know what i
always think about on this show is
whenever we like talk [ __ ] or respond to
someone like andrew tate he probably
watches the episode and sees what else
we say and then you just see [ __ ] like
this and it's like what the [ __ ] how do
i even go at these people you can't
compete
but i do think it's funny whenever
people think say it's just a drama
podcast we're so much more than that
we're
a show
there's so much more yeah yeah
[Music]
it's drama plus fear factor
well i'm a huge fan of fear factor i
watched when theodore was born i watched
every single episode man
love that show
i feel like i have to like
represent sweden in a right way i'm
going to try to get you guys this
authentic swedish cake
a princess torto
tikka time
yeah i want to move back to my seat i
gotta wash my hands i'll be right back
man
another
another beautiful day another beautiful
day
yeah
i peeked twice this week yeah
anyone here from arizona
that's normal at the workplace
all i have to say is you guys were not
kidding
feel like that's what what hell smells
like
yeah i can't believe the power of our
mods though yeah
impressive yeah
i'm super impressed ray especially like
that was just insane
thank you
[Applause]
man okay i'm back
that felt wrong seeing ethan in my seat
that didn't feel a little weird
oh someone asked if olivia is okay is
she okay olivia yeah
oh olivia's just she's staying she's
staying down for people
okay i'm back beef jerky anyone
hell no
tastes like beef jerky
it tastes like beef jerky
i don't actually want this i just
thought it'd be funny
oh that was just insane
i really didn't think it was like that
level that because how can one can do
that
dude like this is a really big space
big open space it's not even a tiny room
it's still pretty [ __ ] up over here
too yeah
yeah what's interesting that i love
about the tsum strowman so much is that
[Music]
everybody thinks they're gangster to
that sumstrom and ken opens right sam
that's right you don't understand what
you're facing until you actually smell
it you know
especially after seeing all these people
like
grabbing those in the
in the video we saw i thought maybe like
maybe it's for some people
maybe some people yeah you think that
these people like them enjoy it no they
prepare it
i don't think it doesn't matter dan
people going to the grocery store and
fighting over cans of that [ __ ]
and then tell me you want to be an ally
with sweden as a country
this is how it's actually served uh
love
yeah
i'm not eating that like tartar
yeah so you see there's a little piece
of fish but there's sauce i'm just
saying onions there's not a better fish
option there
you know what i mean yeah why do you
again
it doesn't taste anything probably when
you prepare it like this
i don't i won't eat it though i don't
know how do you get rid of the smell
like it would take
you open it under water that doesn't
seem like enough no no it is it
definitely is love seems to be
love in an effort to defend his
countrymen is trying to explain away the
horrors of this well there's a reason
why you don't want to open it under
water you said no we got to open it
there no i know but you think opening it
under water makes the fish taste like
[ __ ] pumpkin pie
bro i am literally saying i hate that
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
i want you to go to a if you can go to a
assumed strowman restaurant and try the
way they probably got a restaurant for
it right
you imagine what the factory smells like
will they make that and can that [ __ ]
god
yeah holy [ __ ]
honestly it was nice just watching yeah
nice
calming
god
is the smell bothering you at all or are
you just used to it i'm kind of used to
it to be honest
well you're pretty far away it's easy to
say from that this no you smell it over
too it's [ __ ] up over here either it's
another thing here but i'll say ian once
again
these guys did great but
what you did was something else man
with the bones and the fish
i kind of feel a little sad because the
brand that we had used love said they
just went out of business
right yeah i don't know how the [ __ ] you
go out of business as soon strong and
your product you're literally selling
[ __ ] in the can like how how bad can
nobody's buying it how can you even
distinguish the flavor of one brand
you're being unreasonable hate hateful
right now ethan i think yeah oh my god
how could you say this this is the worst
of our country i'm showing you the this
is pretty this is emotional for me i'm
showing you the worst that that requires
a lot right yeah but you keep trying to
defend them being like yo it tastes like
you
said he would never want it
no he goes if you open underwater and
you [ __ ] rinse it off you can eat it
like a goddamn
lifesaver i'm not hell nah i'm not
defending that [ __ ] i'm just saying how
it's supposed to be prepared
i want word with the secretary of state
alliance with sweden is off
i'm closing the embassy
so i have something to say real quick
so yeah
usually i have
like really bad stomach problems and
i tend to use uh
ginger ales to help my stomach a lot
this was not a good thing to use a
ginger ale for because it makes me burp
a lot oh man
ian i didn't even swallow it you're
right man these burps are horrifying
well i think when ian downed that thing
sam was the real right right
yes our whole house smelled like that
[ __ ]
he was burping
and he threw up in our toilet when we
got home so it was just like
it was [ __ ] nasty was the worst was
the ride home because i like hot boxed
the car with
fish that is true it was fun
yeah yeah so guys we'll get your zell
olivia's back welcome back olivia hi
olivia
olivia your laptop was open on the floor
i know i took the cord with it when i
ran away
yeah so who's ready for pizza
oh you know it boy let's go let's go i
didn't even hesitate i wouldn't hesitate
honestly i would
like it because i think it would help
with the smell here get some fresh buys
in yeah
yeah so anyway guys congratulations to
our mods just
just earned five stacks each
500 subs that's right and cam earned
himself a nice 100
getting a sniffing
avery's breath
well done man well done
there you go the real experience ladies
and gentlemen yes this is why i'm
watching
nice see there you go the people love it
all right well what else how do you move
on from here
let's talk about keemstar speaking of
wanting to vomit
no this is good this is daddy
you're gonna like this speaking of
wanting to [ __ ] die
speaking of wanting to yak and
everyone wants to leave the room as soon
as it comes into it keemstar
speaking of someone who
was a left
okay i should
but there's a lot of similarities and i
like where i like to play with this
[ __ ]
yeah so keemstar he keeps going on and
on
and what's funny about him
is that every time he baits me with
something like this
and then i respond he reports me to
youtube i mean he's such a baby such a
little baby [ __ ] ass bro
so here's the new one and you'll see why
i'm responding to this
so he tweeted this out remember that
time h3h3 called gideon a
sounds interesting let's watch
it's what happened with this with this
one guy
and this guy dijon who by the way i'll
say his credit has apologized
pretty uh pretty fishy right hmm what
could i have been saying it's what
happened with this knit with this one
wow keemstar's really
got me got you dead to right oh wait
well there's this i'd like to see them
wiggle his way out of this one
wait hold on
this was a popular response of course if
you know what this is you know you know
video what do they say gifts that have
sound
in your mind they're all that which is
great you know
but a lot there was a lot of people that
were like whoa what else was he gonna
say yup
there's no other word he could have
possibly been saying people retweeting
it
i can't believe this i'm not surprised
yeah bunch of you know
typical stuff
so by the way by the way look how dark
my hair was though
we pulled that up
on the screen
oh because we didn't talk about it look
how dark my hair was bro i'm going gray
as she
[ __ ]
so anyway keemstar post that
yeah so you might be wondering what was
i actually
going to say
i mean it's not like you
don't stutter on your words right i mean
even by itself it's not incriminating at
all
because when i first saw the clip i was
like that's so stupid obviously i wasn't
going to call my n-word like that's
insane yeah but what happened was we
were like well
the clip he posted is so deep fried and
[ __ ] weird there's got to be more
context to this so okay so we looked up
the context
and you guys are going to love this it
comes from a highlight called ninja
is suing pokeman
this is where he got the clip from
oh my god so you were going to say ninja
so one more time let me open this
hard-hitting [ __ ]
now keemstar
it's what happened with this knit with
this one uh now i can hear it you almost
say nin yeah then you see me yeah i
wasn't going to call him the n-word
that might surprise you but so keemstar
went to a highlight called ninja is
suing pokemane
wow
and uh
for um
it's slow even for him yeah even for a
clown
yeah so wait
where was the part where i said it it's
in the first like 40 seconds so here
i'll just watch this you guys i think i
already made a whole video about this
pokey drama but the one thing basically
pokey mane friend of the show great
great lady big fan
she's gonna come on to him for those of
you who don't know her oh really she's
really she's a big streamer
this is her for those who are not
familiar there was a really interesting
development but i'll just give you the
basic rundown is that some dude was hate
rating her
pokeman gets way too much crap she's
she's a pretty girl
and people just don't like women what
can i say there's it's it's a gamer
culture there's a lot of incels there's
a lot of freaking
betas
and they say well
the only reason she's successful is
because guys fantasize about being with
her and it's pathetic and people always
target her it's what happened with this
ni with this one guy
and this guy dijon
yeah i obviously just meant to say ninja
this story is about ninja yeah it's
about ninja suing by the way i'll say to
his credit has apologized and stuff and
so like i mean that's pretty low in fact
yeah i might that might even be
defamatory
i'm sorry i made a mistake i don't love
it what it shows just how desperate he
is yeah i mean clearly he doesn't
believe it but to go this desperate like
he's laughing with all of his dumb ass
kids that he hangs out with and like oh
you know like obviously it's not what
he's saying but if you're this desperate
to use this what is that what is that
[ __ ] he's exhausted every [ __ ] option
has nothing
nothing
which is good nothing
yeah how much does they have both blacks
what's he got
bet you have nothing
[Laughter]
yeah but this is probably defamation to
be honest and and i mean you throw that
in with the um
when he was accusing me of stealing
funds from the i mean that's that's a
never slam dunk you know ever forgetting
and i just love that he's bitching to
youtube
he's constantly trying to get us in
trouble uh it's so
sad it's so sad this man is so [ __ ]
sad it's funny that you say that because
i looked at the same time to see if keem
reported on the situation and i went to
his twitter and here i linked in the doc
this is uh
keem being a karen on twitter
so the same day
jakeem went back and found this clip
of me s missing ninja and
he the same very day that clip took
place he said dear twitch i would like
to inform you
that says streamer pokeman has sexually
harassed ninja
i know probably no one if it was
offended but rules are rules this was
clear sexual harassment
i mean so he knows about the situation
he's also it's nice to show what an
intel loser he is still yeah
that's that that tweet says so much to
me yeah like the [ __ ] lost it he tried
to claim you're the platformer
he's clearly doing it in like broad
daylight just he's always had time
always has been numbers always has been
that's what he's about yeah
yeah he's just a spiteful loser that
will go to any length to get i mean he
really has some kind of personality
disorder and i i don't mean that as like
a joke i just think like
that's the only explanation for
is twisted for what he does
for the people saying this is not sexual
harassment
imagine if ninja said something about
pokey's genitals he would get banned i
didn't what is he referring to so get
this the sexual harassment that he's
referring to is pokemane said that she
has bigger balls than ninja
that's sexual harassment but when
someone is r-wording you just close your
mouth i close your mouth i don't get it
and just close your mouth keemstar
famously said of the jake paul essay
story
the story was that he forced himself in
into her mouth
and he's like this is this [ __ ] is
lying i mean just close your mouth just
say no
he's done about a few stories that came
out not just jake paul there was the one
girl that like said she froze in a
situation and he was like
how do you freeze yeah just move
yeah exactly and he's posting like these
really weird and silly
[ __ ] photos of her like yeah when he
reported on it that's the photo he used
dude 40 year old dude so pathetic
wow that's sad
that is so sad look at his face i mean
there's nothing there man
that look at that face what does he have
boblox
[Music]
that's too useful
you're right
that's a good one so there's that
you know when someone
someone posts something like that you
said the n word to a black person and it
gets 5000 likes on twitter
then um
then it's worth uh uh defending yourself
by the way somebody donated and said my
porsche has an electromagnetic panorama
roof that features frost and tint glass
are you serious
yeah it's supposedly the model of
porsche you has has some feature that
you can i gotta look at that interesting
um here's another one
when gideon sent a hate raid over to
pokeman's streams spamming l plus ratio
the twitch community the pogers
community said well the rules are the
rules the rules are the rules he broke
terms of service he broke tos he
deserves to get banned
and now that pokeman has said on her
stream that she has bigger balls
the ninja
she has clearly broken the rules
she has broken tos that is sexual
harassment you can't talk about another
twitch streamer's genitals like that or
criticize another twitch streamers
genitals you can't do that if any male
streamer talked about pokeman's genitals
they would get banned because the rules
are the rules now when i put that tweet
out you guys are responding you pogger
community you twitch community oh you
reach it oh you gotta be kidding me no
no no you set the tone you set the tone
last week the rules are the rules she
deserves to be banned she broke the
rules stay mad
wow
bet you have nothing
i'll talk about her genitals keemstar is
a bigger [ __ ] than pokey
got him got smaller balls and a bigger
[ __ ]
got all the parts
yeah so you know just a sh just a short
little thing like because he tries to
get away with this stuff and you can't
really give him anything the man it's
kind of this man it really
has been trying to ruin my life like
actually for years
and it's pretty incredible one more time
just sure it's what happened with this
with this one guy i mean dude
well dude you said you didn't like him
five years ago so yeah right right right
that's kind of it kind of kind of asking
for it a little bit
um i'm sure he's going to write an email
now to youtube saying that uh
i'm harassing him or something
which is
another layer of insane
if i can interject for a moment
i think his tweet says a lot more about
him than you
it comes off both as projection much and
i think it kind of honestly shows his
true colors because
i've seen a lot of dudes
like that who you know i i mean i don't
want to call it performative social
justice but like let's be honest you
know who pretend that like they're
trying to do a cause and stuff to kind
of hide their true colors and make it
seem like you know that they're not
racist and like
and like i i just think that kim just
wants you to be him so bad that he's
willing to go down these low ass links
because let's be honest i mean me
personally i believe keemstar doesn't
really give a [ __ ]
no no of course not zero first nine i'm
sure i'm just using that hard r and yeah
free time you know the secret um my own
personal opinion not reflective of
hatred
yeah thank you for that
yeah
yeah i mean
it's embarrassing i mean a normal person
would be humiliated to tweet something
like that out but he has nothing left
right black bet you have nothing
that was much better zack
bro it still smells so much like
something yeah it's hard
yeah my head is pounding it does
awful my head is pounding
i had to adjust to the smell later than
you guys so i was sitting here for about
five minutes being like
like i couldn't breathe it's still so
bad it's really feel like it's coming
back like the febreze covered it for a
while but it's anticipating yeah it
ain't going away i'm living large out
here my bomb
has settled a bit how are you guys doing
like
you must not be doing
good i'm checked out i think they're all
fine
did you guys all get sick
uh no only a b a b got the most sick abs
the only one that yeah no way it was you
yeah
you're who i heard yeah
you guys rock are you kidding me
yeah
ray just gobbled it down that was
incredible
in the chat ray just swallowed it whole
and replied with like why would she do
that
are you able to
like swallow things like that in general
because i i don't have that ability
right um i am kind of like a goblin when
it comes to food i really like like
macaroni or mashed potatoes i don't
really chew i just kind of inhale it wow
strategy okay yeah i was like i'm just
gonna drop it down the hatch and let's
go
it worked though that definitely worked
gill really came handy today
yeah so i want to talk next about um
there's this really
tesla owners and you know
we have we have a tesla releasing we've
had it for three years and i'm so happy
that and we're getting rid of it because
now there's so many new electric cars
available
i'm not driving a tesla electric car and
then ela's going to get a new electric
car a bmw is coming out with the suv
electric car for the fam
so that's exciting that is cool but um
the tesla go ahead dan it's just
interesting that they
you're trading in the tesla for the bmw
because this is actually an observation
i've been making to people anybody
who'll listen around me lately is
maybe different cities have different
versions of this but in la growing up
here it's been like kind of a meme
forever that like
bmw drivers are like the most aggressive
annoying that cut you off on the highway
like that's always been a thing yeah i
personally feel like
all of those people not all bmw drivers
but the ones that gave bmw drivers that
reputation they all traded in for tesla
yeah that's awesome
now it's all every time i'm getting cut
off every time somebody's driving way
too fast and blowing past you on the
freeway it's always a tesla now honestly
i used to be
to think like that and i could never see
myself as a bmw owner
until i saw larry david drive on
changed the whole context in my head a
little bit
well bmw but he's been driving it since
they had the electric one ah okay he
went a tiny one right he went from a
prius
to the yeah to the tiny electric bmw
yeah but i think the tesla meme is kind
of i think it's becoming a douche car at
least here in l.a i can only speak to la
highways but it it's definitely replaced
bmw in my mind as the douche car and to
be i'm not all drivers i'm sure look
there's so many teslas on the road in la
if you don't live here you don't know
but
um
i'm i'm really happy to see all the
electric cars it's awesome but tesla's
are really douchey car now
it's been
it's been growing on me also the need to
get rid of the car because one elon
obviously just like cannot stand the guy
anymore yeah um but also the second
thing is just learning how much he's
actually just a salesman and a lot of
the promises he made were just fake
like that really
i don't know at first i don't think any
of us saw him like that and when he
would talk about the tesla and what it's
gonna do in a few years
so i i really believed it and um just
the more that came out about him you
learned that he's just like
he's just a salesperson and he he i mean
there's also a documentary that came out
kind of recently that we watched about
him and he would make
um public announcements that all of his
team would not agree with that they were
even capable to actually do right and he
would just like go and say it in events
and they were going they're like that
was the first time we had heard that
yeah he'd go be like we're gonna have
full self-driving cars by the end of
next year and they're like
what
yeah so but anyway that actually moves
nicely into our point which is um
tesla fanboys testing they they just
released this full self-driving feature
what
elon's been promising for like a decade
now for six years at least because we've
had it
and they charged years ago isn't that
crazy it was already saying it then yeah
yeah and they and they sell you the
package for when it's gonna be available
yeah yeah they up so
they charge you like four thousand
dollars and then it'll be available next
year and it never comes they actually
got sued for it
but anyway so they're rolling out now
the beta for the full self driving
feature to like a hundred thousand super
fans to test drive it
and a lot of them have been making
videos testing it and these people these
tesla fanboys are [ __ ] insane
i cannot emphasize and also the car
uh is horrible by the way there's people
saying that the uh your car is gonna
suck that's weird i read online that it
had a really high rating my car really
the bmw yeah was just one person
somebody said a self-proclaimed car
expert ethan's car the uh take can tycan
i love his car by the way they say it's
the best tv available right now but then
they go on to say the bmw ix ela has
coming will be a disappointment
what you're talking about the reviews
for this car have been like literally
almost perfect
there's a thing on the grill where it's
scratch proof so if you get a scratch on
it you can pour hot water over it not
have to worry about compound or buffing
it out and it just comes right off it's
insane that's weird i don't know i
before we bought it we did a lot of
research and like i guess somewhere out
in europe or it's been test drove and
reviewed and it seems like people
[ __ ] love this car so i don't know
i've seen some bad news about it too
well i still especially
probably back out of it no no no i think
i do
no i'm saying don't do it don't do it
yeah if you're really considering buying
it the linus tech tips did like we're
releasing it it's a video we're just
leasing it okay
it's a good video yeah i'll check it out
but i we we actually put the order for
this before we got ethan's car
since then i've
i get to drive that one sometimes and i
love it but we need a family car though
i also a quick story the safety of bmws
is insane my dad was in a car accident
um a few days ago
he's okay he got t-boned but the safety
features in that car is insane it could
i feel like it could have been far worse
if he wasn't and there you go or
something
yeah
yeah i would i would keep it i don't
know
i'll read more about it though because i
didn't know about all this
i guess yeah it came out in the eu
probably so anyway
uh yeah talking about tesla so here
people are making
uh
tests of its capabilities
and this thing is not [ __ ] safe
and tesla's been getting into a lot of
trouble calling their cars auto drive
autopilot it's just it's
it's actually i think causing uh
a lot of harm
giving people a false sense of security
it does and i
watching that documentary really made me
change the way i view it because that's
how i always thought about it
and when you when we went shopping for
other cars no none of them say it like
auto drive they don't even use those
terms yeah and so now with that in
context and
all this new information it's like this
[ __ ] is not as secure as they promised
me and i'm like kind of worried when i
use it no people have died i mean like
many people have died because they have
an over like let's say it's technically
their fault right but they they've been
promised and they have overconfidence in
this uh self-driving thing
here is one there's just a dog right in
front of it on the road you know let's
see oh no [ __ ] destroyed
oh yeah
like that you can't you can't fault the
driver for that what is auto drive for
them well no this is the beta of the
fully automated self drive this isn't a
drive assist this is them saying put in
your address yeah the car drives you
there period got it so that's this is
what that this is supposed to be
here it is slamming through a crosswalk
and running over a dummy child it's
awesome musk's full self-driving tesla
will do when there's a child in a
crosswalk
not
we ran the test again watch the onboard
footage
the test was conducted on a real street
with a real crosswalk outside a school
in santa barbara california
the child-sized mannequin was dressed in
a safety vest to make it as visible as
possible
there were no cones there was room to
swerve and you can clearly see the
accelerator
full self-driving mode is engaged the
accelerator is not pressed and the
tesla's displayed died
dude
the child sized mannequin
i love how they're like we did
everything we could to make sure this
car
didn't run over the shot it gets better
it gets better and better i'm just
setting it up here
here's another one running over a dummy
child
okay
[Music]
look at this
dad
at least it stopped this time
i think that was probably the driver i
was the driver here
that kid is toast
so here's where it gets really really
really nuts
oh wait there's one more this is a
couple using it
showing it off to their friends and they
almost drive into a ditch
i know this is a gorgeous road
intervention that we had so far and i
think that's gonna we're gonna call it
with that
so
here's where it gets good
so these fanboys are determined for
whatever reason to
real-life kids [ __ ] simp for elon
yeah just watch this video dude you're
gonna have a you're gonna lose your mind
actually i think it's worth noting
no no okay let's let's watch i'll just
play it
yeah
yeah so i'm i'm tad i'm a portfolio
manager for b car the autonomous driving
etf and uh
yeah i trust the system enough that
i i've tried fsd beta before that i
would trust my
my kids lives with them
um so i i'm very confident that it's
going to detect
my kids and then i'm also in control of
the wheel so i can break at any time
there you go this [ __ ] said i'm
willing to trust my kid's life to this
what about your kid
[Laughter]
after all those videos why are you even
doing this
let them do the tests love of the game
baby
okay hey can you cross the street all
the way oh my god
what a lunatic
okay not now it's blue it's not it's
blue
all right so it's like a five-year-old
too in it yeah it can see him it can see
him for sure he waits for him to cross
yeah and then it continues
so it's sees kids just fine
yeah it's like it's like they take it
personally when these videos come out i
don't know why
you have to do that and he's he's really
very invested yeah he's only five years
old like part of their identity in the
beginning but uh yeah i knew that it was
going to
he's only five maybe if he was 10 this
one would happen
yeah detect and stop
and i think it's very important for this
to be out there i think it'll save a lot
of kids lives that will be for a
separate test here we come and
oh it actually hits
the child it's with me turning it on
okay it is on and enabled and here it's
moving forward and for a very split
second you can see
the child shows up
so as the child continues to move right
here is where the child shows up and
obviously it was too late for it to
apply the brakes in fact it didn't even
try to apply the brakes at all and just
kept going forward i enable it
and i dial the speed down from 25 i love
that tesla built in hit and run
approved by our boy uh pnp
they consulted with him let's go
all the way down to i think 17. and you
can see it didn't look like a human at
all
and it kind of went straight through it
now there was a point in there and i'm
going to replay it here there's a point
where it actually swerves out of the way
just a tiny bit and it's kind of
surprising to me that it actually did do
that and here are my daughters walking
in front so you can see both of them are
being displayed very clear this man
really put his own [ __ ] kitchen
it just hit
just ran over those fake kids however my
daughter on the left and the yellow
skirt she keeps dropping out you'll see
her kind of fade in and out quite a bit
and i think it might be because it can't
see her legs all the way with her dress
hard to tell on that one but she
definitely fades in and it's a minor
defect it's hard to tell on that one
yeah if you're wearing a dress you get
run over if you throw a frame back you
can still see the fake kid dead on the
floor when you have little
and for the last last test just for good
measure i thought i'd have my daughter
walk in front of my car as it stopped
with your daughter obviously this is
very dangerous so i dial it all the way
down to three miles per hour but as you
can see she is clearly showing up and
this is the daughter with the dress on
she runs back and forth and she's
extremely intelligent and kind of knows
that she's trying to trick the computer
here and she runs toward the car and you
can see she's kind of putting her arm
looks like a fright night yeah well he's
also going only three miles an hour yeah
so it's like let's say residential's 25
mm-hmm
what if you're 60 you're going 60 like i
don't that's not going to work ultimate
conclusion is that girls with dresses
should be in the kitchen
[Laughter]
that's right maybe this wouldn't happen
if we listen to andrew tate that's right
by the way the guy who sacrificed his
own kid to the gods of elon yeah this is
his own tweet he tweeted this
he said is there anyone in the bay area
with the child who could fly in front of
my car
on full self-driving beta
to make a point oh my gosh i won't run
them over we'll disengage if needed this
is a serious request now mind you this
guy was trying to recruit other people's
kids
before he volunteered his own your honor
i promised i wasn't going to run him
over will anyone willing to sacrifice
their kids my wife took mine and left
the house
all for the love of game baby
do you know for sure that that's the
same guy
uh because that is extra crazy yeah i
think it is
yeah it's the same guy what the [ __ ]
he's trying to get other people's kids
before he used it did his own
this man is a menace
also the documentary or it wasn't what
was it was it like an episode of that
new york times on hulu
they have um
it's like an hour-long kind of episode
um check it out it's on hulu i think
they also showed how even on auto drive
they have like an empty
like a blind spot that they know about
right and is not addressed so if if a
car is driving towards like a white big
truck like that it's just gonna go
through that that's how it doesn't catch
it two people died that way yeah and two
people died that way
and also the manufacturing of tesla you
pay so much money for this car
and people have been saying it's very
cheap on the inside like on the plaid
like it was 150 grand it's all plastic
and like
cheap like if you're paying that much
for a car i think you'd want a little a
little better you know
this is great
musk and tesla someone else's kid
legitimate autopilot concern
there's so many great
replies oh my lord listen please is this
one please don't have a child run in
front of a moving car yeah
it seems pretty straightforward
so autopilot stuff is in the long term i
think a really good thing but why how
can you be allowed to beta test that on
public streets like they literally call
it beta yeah something that serious i
don't think you should be able to beta
test based on the public right
you know
the problem was with tesla's as a tech
company they collect data
from all their drivers never be a beta
to improve their software so that's like
their whole business model
i lost faith in tesla whenever me and
ian went to that crypto con
conference and someone had a big tesla
tattoo on their neck oh my gosh
that's the next level dude so committed
man wow
i'm willing to put my own life kids on
the line here
let's go he actually was consulted on uh
on the hit and run policy thank you sam
let's [ __ ] go oh baby mama
dominoes we're playing with fire today
oh no it's already been it
go look at this
black olives
pineapple jalapeno wow
congratulations you're so good can you
grab me a yeah paper towel come on we're
not monsters here nobody's eating just
me
i can make plenty i will if you guys
want me to that's fine i guess if we're
doing this this is the last third are
the mods
oh i'm i'm game
oh
yeah man
except for cam nothing for him not done
can i have something no
no
all right sam i really like the thin
crust one it goes down so much easier
i'm afraid to eat pizza after leftovers
yesterday
even though that wasn't pizza you
already threw up once today you're in
the clear
true mama
um
so that was a fun little test of the
story
did you did you see this
yeah let's go
by the way i figured out how to uh do
the roof of your porsche i can show you
after work are you serious it's really
cool yeah
nobody told me about that
[Music]
you think that like they would have
showed me that right
it's really sweet you have different
options of how much like you want
covered and not what not oh my god it's
very futuristic i've been suffering in
that car you don't understand i bring a
hat in there
really just for that killed my face from
the sun yeah it's amazing how you'll say
something randomly on the show and then
people actually solve
your problems yeah
it's pretty cool
oh yeah that is awesome you know the
other day i talked about how the
donations were
causing for sam's jeep were causing me a
big headache because they come in in
different currencies from all over the
world i had like four fupa troopers that
you know work professionally with excel
and everything reach out to me to uh
hook me up with formulas to do to auto
convert all of them
it's amazing yeah so thank you to
everybody that reached out if you didn't
talk about the rolls royce we would
still be driving that thing
you think because you talked about it on
the show you said how we're we're stuck
with it
and that started the whole conversation
that we're not actually stuck with
yeah i think i don't know
anymore
i'd rather have the sun in my eyes yeah
that thing's so fast
rose rice
yeah dude so anyway let's talk about
this next story i think you'll like this
one hila
addison ray
we all know her
she deleted she oh wow she's so she
actually bailed on this
she posted this shame
shame bikini
it's adidas
yeah
so who why are they blaming her it's a
world [ __ ] wide brand yep so she was
wearing this bikini father and the holy
spirit
um
context from
the fashion world as far as i can
say from my experience i've been
noticing this brand a lot lately praying
i think they're really cool they make a
lot of this kind of style of stuff where
there's like a funny saying on it or
ironic or you know a little edgy
and i think it's a great i think it's a
great piece it's funny and
i love it it's kind of viral this
specific bikini kind of went viral like
a lot of people know it and recognize it
i think it's great but actually i don't
know why she specifically
she gotten so much [ __ ] man and just be
clear the post was just the photo on the
right it didn't even show the bottom
part it was just
the top shame was it an ad
shame
looks like one it looks like one but i'm
not exactly sure if it
i mean it had to have said add right i
mean
it was probably sponsored post
you know
so
she's 21 years old she posted that photo
and then
she got insane backlash you guys
um
like massive here let me pull look at
this [ __ ] this is i love this it's the
best [ __ ] ever
this is the kind of videos people were
making about her to the point where she
really deleted it
god knows how much she made for or she
was on the line from us
post with adidas and [ __ ]
i can't imagine deleting it it's such a
great photo
dude she looks great
well here watch what they're saying
about her i think you should be canceled
for blasphemy i think you should be
shamed
for
wearing something so absolutely
disgusting and disrespectful like you're
one true king
the son of god
jesus christ the one who died on the
cross for your sins
who rose again on the third day
i think you should be canceled and
shamed in your comments section for that
you disgusting pig [ __ ]
oh my god that's really what it is
you're a witch
and i only wish that you know we were
living
200 300 years ago so we could burn you
at the stake oh my god what who's his
favorite creator andrew tate
oh my god that's disgusting this guy
should be
off the internet some of this guy's
dangerous yeah and embarrassing
he's embarrassing himself and how are
you going to talk about fashion your
shirt is ugly yeah
what is this shirt for real
she's got [ __ ] dunked on that hairdo
i mean what are you thirteen
keep going [ __ ] how old is he roasting
leopard print window i mean dude who who
who do you live with your auntie [ __ ]
you're such a [ __ ]
what you said
that was you i know okay i know i know
you know
do you this is just one piece man that
guy's a [ __ ]
um where did he post that i think it was
tick tock
that's not a tick tock format jesus
here's another one it was like
widescreen
people really were piling on her this is
another guy
or a lot of twitter outrage tick tucker
addison ray
advertising for adidas and holy trinity
spirit all i'm going to say is these
people are going to learn the hard way
not to play with god just wait and watch
shut up [ __ ]
retweet
stupid ass so i'm just looking up a
little bit and yeah that guy is a um
america first streamer uh
he is a open um white nationalist uh
club filter
confederate insists that he's not a
nationalist because he doesn't advocate
for an all-white ethnostate but then
admitted that he does believe in white
christian dominance in america and there
should be a white majority in the
country i mean that's that's the kind of
person that's upset about it i am of
course that guy would promise this that
guy would fit right in on the supreme
court i mean
honestly who cares if those kind of
people are upset
apparently she there was enough outrage
though i'm getting it yeah there's
definitely more and it's not all
it's yeah not everybody was as extreme
as calling for her to be burned at the
stake but yeah there are a lot of uh
christians that were upset olivia how
are you just like such a defect of a
human being
like how is everything so wrong mm-hmm
yeah can we can we return him yeah can
we return things
that's what i keep trying to say is that
this is your brain on on deep
fundamental religion fab
for real
there's a whole hashtag trending addison
ray's going to hell
wow
you know the first one
this one has
20 000 likes 120 000 views edison ray
really commit the unforgivable scene
when she published her instagram photo
of this blast from his bikini
danger of the flames of hell now the
answer may surprise you so watch the yen
and hit that bottle if you want a closer
relationship are you really clickbaiting
god the greatest people are so like
extreme uh religious what are they doing
on social media right they probably
justify it by saying
they're missionaries you know what i
mean i don't think god would be down
with social media i don't think god
likes that no he doesn't like that
when you hear that sound in a tick tock
that music in the background you know
you're gonna hear some dumb [ __ ] yeah
rule of thumb
well god according to their bible
uh
dared murder all of job's family
but these are clearly very extreme
people
yeah
i mean normal religious people don't
think that no that's from yeah i agree
no these people are obviously psychotic
but there's a lot of them these days
which is what scares me there's a lot of
views and shares on this it says this in
matthew 12 31 therefore i tell you every
sin and blasphemy will be forgiven but
the blasphemy against the spirit will
not be forgiven addison ray has not
issued an apology to date neither has
adidas for endorsing such apologies for
what a fashion the unforgivable sin is
attributing evil or satanic power to
what we know to be the clear undeniable
work of the holy spirit and jesus said
that is unforgivable back up undone
jesus also said every sin and everybody
will be forgiven addison ray is
blaspheming against the holy god of the
universe launching the holy name of god
for clout and money but god wants to
forgive her sin and he can forgive her
sin because jesus died for her blasphemy
how many times have you blasphemed
against god by using his name as i swear
denying his power in your life or simply
choose to live an open rebellion against
god on your terms
that shirt is a sin by the way this is
the same guy that just asked people to
subscribe pretty sure that would be a
sin
vanity yeah
dude just [ __ ]
god wants you to apologize i love that
in their mind this all-powerful god he's
just such a [ __ ] i need you to
apologize for wearing that bikini it's
like you're omnipotent you made the
whole universe
how can you care about addison ray's
bikini while also being an omnip
omnipotent creator of everything like
bro it doesn't make it's not logically
possible that he would care about this
and also be the creator of the universe
you dumbass
weak-ass hairline [ __ ]
boy
also i feel like
even the even when they're quoting bible
verses
it seems like a little bit of a stretch
like blasphemy like none of those verses
really like
doesn't
it has the name it it says
the sun
on a bikini like is it inherently
blasphemy to write their name on a on an
article of clothing well i don't think
it is
put my name on a on a thong bikini yeah
i mean they just think it's
disrespectful yeah okay
that's an opinion i mean you you there's
no scripture
basis of this like
this kind of vague thing about blasphemy
you you live how you want to live and
let others do whatever the [ __ ] they
want it's just weird i mean whenever you
can justify anything in the bible i mean
people spend their whole
life
dissecting the bible to justify whatever
weird [ __ ] [ __ ] they want to do in
life you know what i mean
according to this line it says god shall
sniff my [ __ ] after i take a dump
that's gospel i don't know you know
i could piece that together probably
this one has a million views 100 000
likes so this ain't a small time [ __ ]
oh i got no audio it's a song
that's it it just says remember the lord
[Music]
this is
okay girl
now cut it out right now
but there's uh here okay i'll keep
looking because there's a whole bunch so
yeah this is the twitter
of course american flag in the
[ __ ] title what did i say
no why do you gotta disrespect chris
why do you gotta disrespect christianity
like that you don't disrespect any other
religion just christianity and why do
you have to create it adidas not that i
was ever a fan of adidas but i'll never
buy anything from adidas and by the way
these are the same people who go like
oh
celebrate draw muhammad day
you know what i mean
it's like shut up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're so fragile
god damn
god doesn't care about addison ray's
bikini
and if he does he's not a god worth
praying to because he's a [ __ ] weirdo
oh jesus the biggest thing is that they
made her delete this beautiful photo i
can't believe that she actually felt too
that's a sin i mean adidas paid her to
post i mean what bigger cosign do you
need yeah
i wonder what christians think about
addison ray's post the underwear says
holy spirit is this not a blasphemy
by clicking delete
and then finally let's see
uh i guess tana wore this bikini earlier
in the year nobody cared isn't that
funny
[Music]
yeah
nobody gave a [ __ ] they're like ah she's
already going to hell
i don't know if she
does alice and ray have more of like
overlap with like
conservative people in our audience i
don't know
i guess i don't know i mean she's way
bigger she's like massive
it has to be they just have
just way different yeah
so shout out to addison ray ladies and
gentlemen um ethan
yeah
i have to admit something to you you ate
my pizza i think you should be cancelled
for blasphemy no
what do you want your olive jalapeno and
pineapple pizza yes
it's growing on me that's right
that's me it's pretty good i'm eating it
right now
i talked a lot of [ __ ] i thought that
was a crazy combo
the way i eat it is just remove the
spicy peppers
but i like that they leave a little bit
of spice on the slice
pizza is the cake i love jalapenos on
pizza i like all of those ingredients
individually it's always just been the
combo that seemed weird to me but you
love it
it's good
i love pizza and i love people
wayne that's me
i love how 15 minutes ago ethan's
headache was so bad he couldn't even
lift his hand headache head what
yeah nice yield
i've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
okay let's listen to this and papa
[Music]
let this play
[Music]
i think
you should be canceled for blasphemy i
think you should be shamed
[Music]
in his language the son of god you
should get cancelled and burned on the
cross through your set
who rose
to burn that stick like whoa can we look
at more of the same to you
i'm into this
where can i find more dalton clove
clod filter
let's see
i don't know where you can post
something like right that's what i
wonder
i will guess i'd love to find out
probably like uh what's that one site
4chan
[Music]
rumble is that what it's called
it doesn't have a tick tock it looks
like the real republican
oh no that was just someone sharing one
of his videos okay
it would probably fly on twitter i think
i found his uh i found his youtube
account
this man's on youtube
hold up
ah you got [ __ ] own [ __ ] that's not
just a joke too i found somebody linking
to his channel and i clicked it and it's
a terminated channel so there you go i
found a stick talk so you're good if you
open that ethan this man has a tick tock
bet you have nothing
oh my god he was banned on tick-tock
what's the one that um
the little nose picker guy streams on
aiden
no it's not twitter
big platform oh right he's a nose picker
too aidan yeah
no i'm talking about the guy that picked
his nose till it bled and then he was
like eating his boogers and stuff oh no
there you go
yeah that guy friend of a friend of
gideon
um
yeah he um
rumble or some [ __ ] yeah maybe it's
rumble
let's find it i want to see what he's up
to i'm sure it's great
well i am kind of glad that it's this
hard to find him yeah
deep deep platforming works people
um
mom and dad an apple pie
yeah maybe it's [ __ ]
wearing bikinis deserve to be
shot and buried
watch kim star sound like that andrew
tate says
women belong in the kitchen
[Music]
you find anything
this man has he's gone yeah yeah i found
a youtube video of some girl reacting to
one of his videos he's he's gone i don't
know where he went yo just shout out to
the internet who memory hold this
[ __ ] guy
maybe god did remember
so there is some justice output
in the world this was a relatively
recent video though so
christian if anyone knows where we can
find dalton claude filter
i just found his gab account that's
where it is
that's i don't know if he's a streamer
on uh cozy tv
getting cozy with the white supremacist
getting posted with the nazis
oh yeah i just opened it and look at
this we got we got uh baked alaska live
right now isn't he in jail let me go to
jail for the january section maybe he's
in jail check it out maybe he's still
let's check it out uh
yeah this oh alex jones is live on here
how many people are watching him oh
alex jones yeah 38 people
so there you go well did you find his
channel uh what was his name again
dalton
38 lawyers just trying to catch every
word he says
here's our boy
bet you have nothing
he says dalton
claude fetter
he's an american first conservative
zoomer and gamer i'm glad he's a gamer
not a combo
wait i want to keep reading his bio
host of good night gruiper every weekday
join the gumroad for all stream replays
social medias are in the link tree
i don't think i think those are all gone
right well
telegram telegram
oh he's he's a partner too
oh this is a partner on cozy tv baby
let's check the replays i want to see
what this guy okay this is from there's
one from 18 hours ago
it says 488 views
so yeah just click to the middle let's
see i'm
we could very easily
show something community guidelines by
i mean
let's just let's take a game i mean
these guys love to throw out the f slur
and stuff i don't know just just warning
you and he's so dead
[Music]
i just clicked a random [ __ ] video
these people have no [ __ ] life like
literally they oh
yeah
you guys might have the right
these people there's like a whole
content universe of people just
reactionary just crying about my content
i'm so blown away yeah wow let's watch
it let's go back and see what he's
talking about
he's well maybe we should take a guess
what could it be that's a good idea your
ugly wife there's gonna you're fat
no it's gonna be classic you don't
exercise i guarantee you this is several
steps beyond that in fact i don't think
that we should watch it oh really oh
there's going to be
caselers uh throwing your way oh stuff
oh my god you think it's that bad
no this is you can say that on this
website just drop it like racial slurs
look at what this is this is
this is the dumpster come on we took a
chance and clicked it let's face it
i'm looking at the comments on that
someone can off-screen file
yeah you watched it
it's just anti-semitism
yeah
i guess i i thought i'm with dan and uh
i don't want to this is the same i can't
watch it i can i can vet it if you want
to send it to me yeah yeah just finding
nice also i love how his shot kind of
looks like mine he looks like he has a
lot behind him yeah
sorry but that was incredible man
yeah i mean that coincidence is super
jump scare yeah but yeah
blind watching that is dangerous
territory we already took a risk and it
paid off i'm just yeah let's keep
following the thread let's be
professionals
we wouldn't have that had that great
moment if we were professionals let's be
thankful for that great moment and you
got to walk away
see there is a guy walk away while
you're up that wasn't amazing i never
walk away while i'm awake just let ab
screening he's watching i sent it to him
maybe he can find something funny that
we can react to that doesn't listen to
when
seeing somebody in chat saying they're
dropping m bombs too yeah
bombs are you serious you oh my god
they don't give a [ __ ] this is this is
like the hardcore griper neo-nazi [ __ ]
well they've been banned from it so i
think they just say like let's just go
all out
right and bombs bro i mean that's just
based off of somebody in our chat that
maybe pulled it up
maybe you'll let us know if you hear
anything good
let us know as you're listening yeah if
there's any gold in there we'll shout
out with the kanye song but i'll keep
you posted
shout out to dalton uh claude fetter who
is a
very well adjusted young man he's
probably watching right now and a
fashion icon let's not forget
who is sitting next to a leopard print
uh window
curtain i mean we can't take solace in
the fact that i mean
nobody's watching this yeah yeah that
video had 400 reviews so yeah
love you buddy keep keep keep hustling
okay bet you have nothing i'll never
i'll never strike you or claim your [ __ ]
okay you you have full rights to this
go get it buddy find god
find god here's my jew horn say
something about it
here i'm even gonna i'm gonna throw you
a bone
jew horns
um what else does anyone have some money
i can hold my hand death to all
jews trying to help you out
okay let's do this while we fit while we
chug our pizza
oh [ __ ] should we do the trailer one
i've been putting that off for so long
put it off
[ __ ]
it's so good though
let's do a discussion i'm very curious
we had it we're having a heated debate
here
what is the optimal temperature
for your house
apparently there was huge variety of
responses i need to pee
yeah i can set it up
what was that the [ __ ] was that
somebody struggling with that i'm sorry
i tried to did you burp but it came out
i thought it was vin diesel bro
oh my god that's swallowing it i
genuinely just didn't know what that was
i'm gonna go pee and then we'll we'll uh
discuss uh okay ela go ahead
go ahead
what well do you want me to i can give
the background of where this discussion
point came okay
uh we were talking before the show
and somebody commented how hot it was in
here
i was like
it feels pretty comfortable in here i
looked it up and you know it's been
really
[ __ ] hot in la the last week or two
but today
we're around where we are it was like uh
79 outside which you know is starting to
get a little warm but to me like 79
that's that's still a really nice day
yeah especially coming off it was nearly
100 for like the last several weeks
that's nice so i was like yeah you know
it feels pretty nice in here in fact the
ac is blowing on me so i'm almost like
chilly i put on the beanie today
and
these psychopaths on the crew
start arguing with me
that 79 is like a furnace and it should
be like
66
64 degrees inside cam said 60 is like
it's like heaven for him avery and i
were just having a sidebar and he said
62. yeah 60 baby
[Music]
i love it yeah
we every night i sleep with the fan on i
go as like as like
as underwear as possible when i walk out
at night i always wear shorts doesn't
matter if it's snowing or not i'm i'm
always 60 or lower i love the cold i
never feel more alive like when i'm cool
yeah dude i love wearing them
see some people that don't use
fahrenheit because
you're not uh in the us but uh 60
fahrenheit is about like 15 celsius to
give you uh
to give you impression
we used to have a friend in new york
that was it left to keep it like
freezing and we would have to bring a
jacket with us when we get see that's
just his house if you're having to wear
a jacket indoors
you're doing it
no you're over doing it doing it right
your mega overdoing it the correct
answer is 68. no that's correct and my
logic behind that is it is so much
easier to warm up than it is to cool off
if it's too cold but you're controlling
it
right and you're like so you're like
energy to run that ac controlling it to
a point that you don't need to over
correct right right but it feels so cozy
like i love
making it just a little bit too cold and
then
you like snuggle up and it feels very
safe if it's too hot it's all you can
think about
you know what i mean
i agree being too hot isn't it too much
because i know we're also waiting for
ethan yeah
yeah you guys
it sounds like we're on the on the wand
side of this on the way inside and to be
clear i'm not saying 79 is my no no but
i'm just saying like that's not to me
that's not bad that's like that's a
little warm but overall pleasant and
it's not 79 in here it's 79 outside and
we're running the ac and you guys are
all complaining oh it's like an oven in
here so i mean should i say what our
temperature is
we keep it at 72.
i think that's super easy and that's
like a little chilly
yeah nice
72 is not awful that's not off that's
like fine and if if sometimes i get too
cold then i turn it to 73 and that's
like chilling that's warm
that's warm yeah see that i'm like how
is that warm that's like
ideal temperature right there
if it's on 72 i can live with it but
it's
it's on the brink of like i wish i was
just a little bit more chilly you know
we're we're spelling the bins about our
temperatures quite a little bit yeah so
what did i miss well go ahead it sounds
like us and then are the only ones in
this room
in agreeance about
the temperature who's talked about it
already
sam
yeah and she's getting a lot of support
from other members of the crew cam cam
says lower than that it can't yeah it
can make it 60.
okay so my question is this what are you
guys wearing yeah right
they say they bundle up which it's like
yeah cause it's too cold why would you
want to bundle up your house no i don't
bundle up i wear like shorts and a
t-shirt i bundle up at home
i like to feel cozy and safe i don't
know what it is i think we
all prefer the cold for the most part
and we freeze dan but dan is a humble
king and he just takes it for us he just
deals with it i always see him in a
hoodie like with his teeth chattering
because see
i'm
like when i'm at home
i like to feel like the optimal
comfortable temperature i'm wearing my
boxers and a shirt that's it
right yeah
i don't understand you want to wear a
sweatshirt at home yeah but you have
something like soft and
i don't know it just means i like the
way it feels when i there's something
very soft to get i guess you just like
the way it feels when they're but i um
like i can't i still like sleep with a
heavy blanket at night but we still have
it at 72.72 is as cold as we'll go yeah
72 is as hot as i will go
by the way oh that guy is non-stop stars
so i say we just skip it i know it yeah
see i knew it without even watching it i
just wow i know that entirely even got
into it it's just yeah
oh my god yeah
i love that for him yep
i can't imagine why he got banned on
other platforms yeah yeah good point
what do you think are like the good
temperature points to all that
now but also i wonder how close are you
to the ac
because like if i go in certain houses
that have like indirect ac or
less good ac
you can crank that [ __ ] down all the way
and like you know you can be at 60 and
maybe it's not that cold
is that what's going on possibly or you
guys have good ac
there's like a vent near my bed
we do not have central ac
so we are cranking that [ __ ] all the way
down that makes sense to me but it also
like in a bigger space i feel like 72 in
this office is like fine but 72 in our
house would be miserable 72 in your
house would be fine
like it depends on the size that's what
i'm saying i wonder
but 68. we're that far off that's the
sweet spot zach your dad once you
mentioned to me when he was showing us
houses he said my house is so cold i can
hang a meat
that's stuck with me
we did keep it cold i mean it wasn't 60
but i mean it was average 70
you know that seems you know
trust me he's hanging me
by the way this is alfredo veggie you
might like that white oh my god i'll
trade you thank you
i just want to eat your pizza
i just grew up in new england
temperatures so i think i'm just used to
it and like it then what do you set the
heat to during the winter
during i don't even know i just whatever
he doesn't [ __ ] the heat yeah whatever
doesn't freeze the pipes you know i'm a
caliber dude cold all the way 60 degrees
t-shirt shorts i don't care nighttime
walking around my flip-flops even if
it's knowing i walk around the shorts
which i've been to a few snowy places
it's all about the cold turn on them
fans open them windows cold supremacy i
don't know what y'all talking about like
like this temperature's fine
you can go colder do it
i'm with it
i'm kicking
i'm always
buttoning down the ac
i think that's sweet
well we don't have acc in sweden at all
okay love is sitting and a hoodie in his
bedroom so i don't know well right now
i'm just wearing the hoodie because i
don't i don't really like having
t-shirts on camera i don't know is the
bottom left there love is that your
temperature right now where you're at
yeah it's like the general temperature
in sweden it's not super accurate but
it's in my room it's probably like 70 79
right now because my pc is running oh
that's hot
yeah
my pc just makes my room so hot and it's
kind of like warm outside too you're
hungry
i've been so hungry and you know what
mcdonald's is closed after 12.
uh
yeah they could get a hold of the owner
so we can campaign them
no i haven't yet no
do they do it do they do over there the
egg mcmuffin meal
oh
yeah i think so but sweden's it's a
little bit different i don't like the
breakfast cheering i i didn't mind it in
america though but yeah in sweden it's
yeah well it doesn't seem like there's
that big of a conflict here
because it really depends on the room
i think it was can we talk
it seems like in here
uh then it still feels too cold i don't
know if you noticed they are we all got
fans now
that's true well are you hot right now
dan
no i feel like it's it's extremely
comfortable in here yeah it's a
comfortable temperature i feel that way
i feel like at any moment i could spend
time spontaneously combust you're that
hot emerged in flames
dude there's been times when the
thermostat
will need to be done
there's been times when the thermostat
in here is like [ __ ] 80. every time i
come in it says 85 i think it switches
to that or it like yeah at night
this building
this building has no insulation and it's
a massive
space
oh pokeyman's in chat what's up what's
up oh what's up
we're excited to have you on the show
yeah we actually we got to pick a date
another date down dan
optimal indoor tech
i must say i guess beside other side
love
[Laughter]
wow
68 see that's freezing that's that's
insane see
68 is [ __ ] cold as [ __ ] this is what
i'm saying you're saying like there's
not that much of a conflict i i think
there is i i
well amy what do you keep your house at
my apartment probably 72.
around there that's because are you
compromising with lena no no we both
like it cold but she used to hate it i
don't know what what happened lena
because linda used to hate how cold i'd
keep it but uh
i've converted her
or did she just do it for the marriage
no she freezes me now sometimes she'd be
dropping it lena
what's the optimal temperature in your
apartment
i just don't like
too cold that's my only condition
amy says that you freeze him out
thoughts
i freeze no he's always freezing
dude
i'm telling you recently she's been
freezing the house
thoughts
it's him he likes it warmer for some i
mean no he he always makes it too cold
yeah and i'd have to like layer up and
put on it like a t-shirt and a
hoodie
to me abe that you have possibly deluded
yourself into thinking she likes it
yeah explain me
i'm just trying to say man would you be
happy alina if he
compromised a little bit and put the
temperature up just a little bit for you
let's just let it all out she's becoming
me and i'm not liking it i like that we
when we got married we're opposites
she's staying up late she's [ __ ]
freezing me
i don't know what's going on like i like
it when i'm up alone i can work and be
productive now she's awake awake working
as well which i love
talking about he's the one that makes it
really cold but i haven't
played and he doesn't like it
okay
could you rolling much
i'm just kidding just saying i know
you're just kidding right
right i mean right
[Laughter]
so okay interesting well um
this guy's pretty serious you guys
anything you guys want to get anything
out and open uh
any other you guys need us to mediate
anything
you okay yeah yeah
you go bro we've had enough of my family
drama on the air oh that's what's there
for next week that's true let's call
your mom
yeah
that's rhonda what's up
[Laughter]
you good bro it's been since selena
became a gamer girl she's staying up
late gaming huh
and she's so i love her voice of an
angel but she's so loud she reacts to
everything the whole stream
yeah and then it doesn't help when you
come up on me and scare me on purpose
uh i do this sometimes i can't deny
[Music]
a small apartment
it's a studio so what are you trying to
do while she's hooting and hollering
i don't know it's weird what is she
disturbing of your activities well i
usually try to work or something or just
watch tv but i can't because then her
mic will pick it up oh well i mean she
does she goes through the same thing i'm
not saying it's just yeah yeah if he's
working lena you should really keep it
down
[Laughter]
he's just trying to sleep or something
then [ __ ] him yeah whatever yeah you
know but i am the one who encouraged her
to stream and she's been liking it so if
she's happy i'm happy
[Music]
shout out lino
gamer girls unite
content queen although i'm really
curious what uh that one guy thinks
about you gaming uh what's his [ __ ]
name
dalton douche dick
dalton douche duck
don't do something i burn him i burn her
out of steak yeah i wish we lived 200
years ago i could burn you dude he'd be
a tier three sub
he probably is
okay so pokemon they watch us all the
time because we could just skip to a
random part
he's talking about love that for him
yeah well it seems that the overwhelming
majority
is 44
68 fahrenheit 20 celsius
yeah i'd be happy to know either we're
not that weird we're we're the second
one 72 72. to be honest though i like 70
i like it at 74 sometimes
oh my man i'm not what i'm saying 74 is
nice no i agree me too i think that
that's i think that's uh it depends on
the day
yeah yeah i mean by the way it's like
what humans are so pathetic bro we have
somehow survived this harsh planet
and we're like discussing off one or two
or three degrees
uh our comfort levels inside of our
[ __ ] shelters i mean
we've taken this humanity thing way too
far yep i just at 74 it just seems a lot
i don't know pokey what's your ideal
temperature you're still listening
74 forever dude 72
69 69 that's a good temperature 69
respectable oh she just said temperature
debate warmer during the day sub 70 at
night subset that's respectable i like
it cold when i sleep so you could really
smell i can understand if you wanting it
a little bit colder at night i will
concede that but that that's like 72 for
us yeah 72.
yeah yeah
there you go pokeman everybody learning
the uh
yeah the hard-hitting 74 is so hot i
you know
i guess it's
growing up
in southern california where it
regularly exceeds 100 degrees during the
summer
i guess
i may be biased a little bit towards the
warm temperature i i can admit that
look it's just to me 74 is like
great yeah like that's a great [ __ ]
day when it's 74 outside yeah well i
feel like the temperature outside versus
like what your thermostat's at is a
completely different ballgame he's right
i'm with zach on this one
well once it gets in the 80s i'm [ __ ]
miserable like once it hits 80 plus it's
game over for me outside pokey also said
did you know making your temperature
cooler at night actually helps you sleep
longer better there you have it pokemon
sleep study pokemon that's today's
pokemon fact pokemon [ __ ] brought to you
by a member by the way pokemon i love
sleeping with the like comforter even in
the summer so you gotta get that down
gotta be cold enough by the way
maybe a tier three she got the little
flame in her icon
which means she's been around for a
minute so shut up shut the [ __ ] out oh
really yeah she got the flame oh you're
right kind of assumed
yeah
pokey's a tier three
yeah love that for her i'm pretty sure
you have to
have been a sub for
like two years at this point to have the
flame i think it's 94 who years is the
blue flame oh it's the blue yeah but the
red flame you get after
i i forget four or five months something
like that so it's still a decent amount
of time shout out pokey yeah yeah
by the way pokeman should we schedule
when you're coming on the show
next week we have tim dillon on
wednesday okay
dude the next week did any of you guys
watch this special by the way i wanted
to watch it last night bro it's so funny
let's play for tonight yeah so um and
then maybe the next week are you
available pokey on like wednesday i'm
trying to schedule this through yeah i
mean we're here we're we're both here
why not
next summer
friday next next and two wednesdays
what's that uh a date maybe the 31st
would be the wednesday i mean if hila
wants to be here maybe we do it on
friday well you could alright or she
could just come in okay
yeah okay well the 31st is that
wednesday so 31st at 1 pm pokey how are
we feeling about that
you want to uh give her the address to
real quick yeah write this down i'll
send that in private message of course
yeah so tim dillon is coming in next
week super funny
you know i like him
he
i think it's the most i've laughed at
especially since like
louis ck's prime days
when he would come out and just
pre-cancellation right yeah yeah
oh my god it was so good
yeah he said actually friday might be
better friday the second okay i'm gonna
send you a dm
but that sounds good okay i think
that'll work all right we'll tentatively
work
you sure you don't want to just give the
location right now i mean she's here
it's okay
sure
uh anyway so that's that
and that's that that's a long episode
right there how long we've been going
there fellas somebody keeps asking for a
break three hours and ten minutes update
you want to give a bruise
just the cutest
he always smiles is just like a little
ball of happiness
dude he's the happiest baby i've ever
seen he's just the best the cheerless
like
you dream of an easy baby and that's
what bruce is he's just like
no problems
not not only that but he's just he
sleeps he smiles he's like
all good pokey said she'll pull up right
now
wait i'm gonna send you a dm so we can
pen this in during the show
but i think we've decided on this did we
say the second dan yes second of
september yes sir
september at
1 pm and then can you send me the
address dan because i don't know
just in the group chat bro
we just had this conversation last night
yeah i don't i can't remember [ __ ]
listen albert einstein once said why
remember things
that you can pull the information on and
i have a beautiful mind and i you know
we have a lot in common yeah how did he
say that i wonder he said like
hold that up you could just text me i
think he said
pull that up pull up that quote it's
transformative
just remember if it's good enough for
einstein it's good enough for me what is
our address down i'm sending it to you
right now
this man owns this property
well if i ever need the address uh i'm
sure i can find it in an email or
something
never memorize something you could look
up campaign thank you
albert einstein who was that kid albert
einstein oops i just sent it in the chat
oh [ __ ] just kidding
god
so funny that you couldn't right
land land all right pokey i sent you the
time and address
and uh by the way pokey's been a sub for
six months so shut the [ __ ] out to a
real one she says perfect
there it is
it's all
happening it's all happening get that on
the calendar dan
it's already on we got it let's go
when
when
w dan
guys yeah and this is
this is truth man never and he says he
says don't
he's not like you can he says never
never memorize
something that you can look up
never
as a command
so you know whoever's remembering the
dress here losers
all right whatever i just i don't have
enough room in my big beautiful brain to
be oriented numbers
addresses
she said just put it in my calendar
can't wait to see everyone
heart
yay
oh thank you i'm very excited pokey i
appreciate you stopping by uh before we
sign off
we have one last surprise for our
wonderful mods here today
it is mod appreciation day here at the
podcast we put them through quite a lot
i'm not gonna lie
so
it's only fitting that we end on
something sweet
we have
custom
h3 podcast
cupcakes
[Applause]
let's eat them
also
um
apparently that albert einstein quote
don't
say it
it's real that's a real one so it's not
that it's completely fake but what he
said was actually
different tell me what he said a very
very simplified version of it what did
he say he said he was asked but did not
know the speed of sound
uh as included in the edison test when
this was pointed out he said i do not
carry such information in my mind since
it is readily available in books
he also said the
education is not learning of many facts
but training the mind to think
so there's like a little
it's a little more it's a little more
intelligent yeah it's correct about that
they kind of they did them dirty with
that
did you make this sam no i would
thank you look at that awesome podcast
emblem
i love it
cheers everybody
cheers thank you to the mods
avery kevin ray
legends
[Applause]
legend legends
so
as we uh
wind down here anyone got any
interesting weekend plans
i'm going to see a very famous artist
tonight
um zach zach lewis let's go buddy the
exactly is going to get schmemmered and
sleep at our house it's tradition and
maybe he can hear lena's stream and see
what i go through
as long as you keep it cold i'm there oh
yeah how long's your set zack um about
an hour and a half
oh and then it's a whole show yeah um
and then i'm doing like an acoustic set
before main set and then i have an
opener
and then oh yeah it's it's gonna be a
lot of fun
wow and we're gonna rock the house
tonight did you get a better deal from
the
club owner right yeah it's i think so
right it's in l.a um yeah yeah full of
alcohol sold out yeah where is like
zach's fourth show that was completely
sold out last time they had to stop
letting people in oh so shout out yeah
hold on hold on
are you getting paid zach yeah yeah yeah
i split with the band we started get we
we need to look into like bigger deals
for you at this point well it's it's
it's on the track there um next after
this uh playing the troubadour so
that'll be a bigger venue that's crazy
to me the troubadour is like same
legendary legendary legendary la venue
so that's that's rad as hell wait how
many seats is that oh it's 500 about
500.
it's more about like the prestige though
because like
yeah people have been around like a lot
of really [ __ ] big acts
like a manager or something um i have a
booking uh dude um his name's david and
um i'm just you know posting all my
social media and
just playing tunes and having a good
time and we're just going up there to
jam and you know play some kick-ass rock
and roll so cool yeah the troubadour
that's on january 13th so
wow yeah
proud of you thank you can people buy
drinks and stuff at the troubadour yes
and that's actually going to be an all
ages show can you get mozzarella sticks
of the troubadour i'll get mozzarella
sticks yeah i don't think they do
i'm just filling it out yeah
you know who you know who i
don't don't you know
please recorded playing at the
troubadour i have a guest
[Music]
i actually i think we all have a guess
zach now that you've brought it up is
gonna fall through a trapdoor in the
stage
john [ __ ] fogerty my dude
what band was he in
i believe they're called clarence clean
water klein water uh water resurrection
galvin klein water
clavin clavin klein water
carving
[Laughter]
i love that bam
what's one of their songs clavin klein
water
uh
i'm blanking
[Music]
thank you
please do not curse me tonight have you
ever
seen nothing
not today don't do it this is a big
happen this
i thought we i thought we killed the
curse we defeated the curse
like we've pushed this curse to it's a
max bro nothing happened i'm just i'm
superstitious about tonight i just i
don't okay you're gonna have a great
night any other day just so let me ask
you this yeah now that we've mentioned
the curse
now that we've mentioned the curse if
you go out and have a great night do we
consider that curse busted or no sure
we can we can talk about okay okay well
you know almost at every show i've been
to so far there's been some dude that
screams it out please some credence
right nothing happens
everyone in chat type in uh reverse the
curse right now reverse thank you first
let's get some reverse the conversion
thank you cam get some river you know
what i was thinking uh zach i'm gonna
show up in the back door
uh with a present it's gonna be the
cursed brim with the cosby doll in it
i'm going to be playing clyded fine
water revival that'd be pretty [ __ ]
funny i'm not even going to lie
um
question
the big
beautiful h3 podcast logo on these
cupcakes edible of course it is it is
fondant got it look at the ice cream bro
i mean they didn't ask questions like
first second
credible i just ate it
it just kind of feels like rubber so it
was a little like a machine that does
that
it's fondant and i'm pretty sure they
probably just use like a cookie cutter
but how do they get like get the logo oh
yeah it's edible ink it's like a printer
oh yeah cool so it's fondue
yeah
yeah what did you say i'm sorry yeah
fondue
got it fondant fondue
fondue fun fun don't
did bon already did
believe it or not there's still 35 000
people watching this why
exactly well everybody
have a great weekend a good ass [ __ ]
weekend
have fun at zach's show everybody what
me and ethan are doing this weekend
we're getting together buddy
okay can we talk about this
this is [ __ ] awesome this is
how did they
one of the best photoshops i've ever
seen is this about a scene from big
lebowski no it's a breaking bread
oh breaking bad so dan your mic is a no
i'm walter white and he's jesse oh
okay but why didn't i make my boy so
wait i'm jesse jessie's not that big
but it's i mean obviously it's been
heavily altered but if you see the
original frame it's um bro this looks so
[ __ ] real it's a masterpiece
like look at dan's face i mean w dan
look at this
zoom in on that that's stan it even
gives cam's approval so you know it's
interesting oh it's it's this is far
beyond me this is a masterpiece oh yeah
this is a masterpiece this is the this
is the heisenberg of photoshop
they must have been on blue meth
[Laughter]
we gotta frame this we gotta know who
made this uh i can it was from the
subreddit so let me shout him out
actually leonardo da vinci maybe
[Laughter]
yes so me and dan of course we have
reservations at denny's
resurrection they take reservations yeah
for me
you have a booth it was posted by
somebody called find the lock as their
username so shout out find the lock we
are blown away
i wonder what i said to dan that
disappointed him so much
i think you just let out a big fart no
yeah oh yeah he said what partner up the
storm again you said what's what's the
building address again
oh yeah you asked for the address
all right guys have a great weekend
thank you to our three mods who joined
us today it's a lot of fun
thank you to the crew for another great
week of content that's four episodes yes
sir
we've got another four next week wait
never stopping
[Applause]
nope unless keemstar gets his band
somehow
those scrolls out of chat please not
funny
all right everybody have a great weekend
thank you for watching
this is the h3 fam
saying see you next week
everyone was waving to the camera
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ass just
like the phoenix on the flex back